and so what I learned about Central Asia
is it's hardly even about Central Asia
it's about the human race and so that's
why I traveled to these places so I can
come back with a story that sounds like
some prismatic weird non sequitur some
ricochet off where I've been like what
did India teach me the times I've been
there the humanity is beautiful even
when it's dipped in its own fecal matter
when you see a body on a funeral pyre on
fire you watch it [ __ ] ours to watch
some old dude burn which I've done a few
times you just go we'll sis life is just
death nothing to trip on because the
family is watching grandpa burn they're
not crying they're not tripping we'll
see him later you know you know the
they'll see him in another life they're
not even sweating it as a Western you're
like guys are fired damn they're looking
at you like a tourist yeah they don't
care it's just life and this is the
wisdom of travel because you can't get
this from a documentary because you
can't smell it you can't get it from a
book if you're not walking over it my
first day in India I saw nine dead
people
welcome to our shippers skeptic tank I'm
Ari Shaffir my final hours in
Scandinavia I'm in Stockholm Sweden
Stockholm Sweden
what a wonderful time I had great final
show great this cool theater so cool the
red velvet seats well yeah it looks like
a place where they CH where they would
have a showing of King Kong you know no
not the movie I mean like did wheel them
up there maybe a place like that not as
big you know maybe not like maybe like
Prince Kong stupid but they'd have
something like that there some freak
show but like a big show not like one of
those you know carnival where you just
go in tent to tent pay your nickel and
go in and ghost go Lux laughs face to
face set a guy which most likely just a
[ __ ] clue Don beard no I mean like a
show a freak show
King Kong but smaller one of those
theaters [ __ ] cool three layers three
levels you're save us on the top level
from a rampage and King Kong right
that's how you think till he gets to
climbing that's our natural instincts
with them climb where does that take you
yeah
third row yeah all over you guys second
rows where it's at second rows where
it's at
he's gonna climb over yeah you gotta
think he's gonna climb up there so if
you're in the first few rows of that
second level at second tier you might be
in danger
absolutely but he's going further up
he's going to the top so unless you're
out and unless you're inside the
fingerprint range like zone and I would
think that means either it's gonna go
outside or do they go straight up and
down in the middle I think they may go
straight up and down in the middle so if
you're in the corners in the front row
that's a good seat that's a real good
seat you'll get a I mean you'll see
you'll see people die you'll see
something that crumpled and just
they're left side just shoulder down but
shouldered like down to like waist so
it's like we're right we're dick with
just like just inside the dick straight
down it was just good that just breaks
apart on a man and you see him like not
quite get it you know know something's
wrong
he's only he's only half now but but
it's like the shock won't let him fully
get it you know
so is it yeah uh-huh
and then that the blood loss starts
catching up to him so now he's not gonna
get it he might never get it he might go
out with his his final moments just
being just just confusion that's not the
way you want to go out that's not the
heroes exit just confusion and you look
at that from your front-row seats you
look at that and you're like now I know
what that's like to see so anyway so
what's going past you is going up now
there is a danger if those tears can't
hold him the calm if they're not strong
enough form and he gets up one level but
then just brings that thing down then he
doesn't get to the third level whole
second levels dead I mean dead you got
from one flight up you got to think
you're not going straight down right
it's not like a trapdoor opens up he's
bringing the balcony down to so there's
gotta be some bounce äj--
unless he pulls it out like behind him
you know on the fall he's probably
shoving it a little forward into the
into the retaining wall that was that
was holding up the balcony and that had
slowed down some you jaws although that
jaw so might really hurt you if you are
on one of those levels but anyway you
probably it probably got you probably be
gone cuz plus then then now you're on
the bottom
oh and the people right below that
little believed below the overhang
they're all gone
in the case of a [ __ ] tear to tear
on the bottom level underneath that tier
2 that's all collateral
that's all statistics instantly you
can't get a balcony fall on you and be
okay
there's not even a little bit of oh
maybe he's okay no I mean the guests
against the guys in the outside like
just under they might get hurt or
shoulder tear I bet one guy would just
get like like it would yank his jacket
down a little on the way down the foot
before or like the wind would get him or
he would like he would feel like a ghost
touch just that barely barely missed him
I mean he'll have a story to tell that
people aren't gonna believe I could feel
the touch just on my hair it grazed my
hair there was a nail that I still feel
like it though you can see a scratch the
nail scratched me ever so light on the
way down
I could feel it I can feel the Kong's
breath he was mighty he knew the end was
coming for him he was scared but also he
was graceful his majestic a word I can
use here I think that's what I would use
majestic I turned he let me live he
could have could have easily said no see
this party's lying he's lying this part
what really happened though was the
thing barely did miss him the nail might
have happened where it scratched out
although that would've Johnson blood so
he's got a little scarf but it's cool
scar on your arm that's cool
don't cut yourself kids but does look
cool so that be down and then he'd
rampage around the second do you think
he'd try for the third level again no
the Kong Island couldn't get up a third
level he got to go second to third so in
that instance third you'd be great in
front row of third I mean front row of
third you could look straight down they
could see the blood splatter probably of
the bottom level with the with a balcony
falling on them they could see that the
blood flow when it's like the won the
juicer happens
I call it juice replication of the
bottom level yeah they'd be fine they'd
be able to see it really and the guys
behind them like what what he look Oh
what what what happened down there what
was the crash oh I was gonna pay for
Lowe's tickets but I got balcony instead
what happened though what went down down
there was I heard the crash what was it
I mean I was gonna do that man I was
signed up to pay for those pay for what
why are you talking about that what's
going on what was that crash what was
the crash Ticket Master locked me out I
was gonna do it I was I went to the
other sites to see this view from the
seats and then when I went back it still
said I had two minutes left was counting
down 157 1-6 so I went yeah it's
purchased buy the tickets and take a
messenger to no you got to start over
however I went back in there you don't
get the tickets again what tickets
what's happening down there is someone
hurt it did someone get hurt
where's the call now where's the Kong
Mikey Mikey where's the Kong but they
yeah why the time I got back in the
system
I wouldn't let me get those same tickets
so we got it I got balcony instead of
Lowe's would have went right back there
either I can see by that back second or
the bathroom a lot but balcony does have
it bathroom - aye it's less people when
you think about her
so um yeah that'd be that'd be the
instance of the balcony going down Horry
could just kind of run through and then
go through out the back doors then you
just get some people on the bottom level
bottom levels in a lot of trouble unless
he makes the top unless he's get into
the top level that bottom levels really
taking the brunt of the damage and
honestly he still gotta get to the back
of the room to get to the levels even if
it will hold up for him
balcony to balcony three even those hold
up for him he's still stomping people on
the way back there he's not doing that
flying Kong thing
so I play the plays like that in uh in
Stockholm the liberal looks like that
it's really pretty cool so dot TX red
Stockholm was fun walked around ran into
Yoshi Yoshi OB ah she was here hung out
with him last night hung out with him
tonight didn't open mic tonight all all
[ __ ] Swedish except for me and Yoshi
he's tall her Kyoshi it's so dark I like
when you get a crowd of both them to
laugh or someone's alive really hard and
something to laugh okay and someone to
do the cringe like oh I like watching
that I like turning like if I'm laughing
at a joke and attorney and seeing that
reaction also I'm like oh yeah it makes
my life feel better
oh I laughed at that pretty hard I got
hurt it's like saying to me throw up at
the end of a roller coaster like wow it
wasn't good I knew his go ride like I
barf that cringe that's that's the UH
that's that comedy version of that of
the roller coaster somebody barfing
having a great time in Scandinavia
Iceland was amazing went to these
amazing places I'll talk about it on the
intro to a [ __ ] Iceland podcast Batman
had some amazing times in Iceland and
uhm Bergen real quick in and out no time
really fun show but no time really
pretty city the weather got nicer she
was back from Weiss from the weather
held up in Iceland too and then I got to
Copenhagen took a bike rented a bike
wanted a bargain that got out from 120
to 100 and then found out it's like
twelve to one so six to one six to one
so it's 20 bucks 20 bucks for two days
for 24 hours of biking that's fine
and um biked all around oh my god it was
lovely sorry that sounds but I mean that
really what a great city bike it must
have to be Iceland for three days all
cold bundled up I got my thrift store
jacket from from
that I bought I think excuse me charity
shop just for Iceland cuz I couldn't
take a look an overcoat with me I didn't
pack good you guys I packed like an
[ __ ]
I brought a duffle bag I mean I parked I
packed it [ __ ] two in the morning
when I was leaving at 4:00 to go to
Montreal in the summer then to [ __ ]
Edinboro then Scandinavia and then Tampa
Bay Florida all in one trip and I had to
pack like that
I brought a duffel bag I what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] not nearly enough and the wrong
thing so many of the wrong things
not enough t-shirts anyway whatever
so I biked in Copenhagen it was so nice
out I went down at the end of the river
and past those barracks past those
barracks that they had the last time I
was here at this guy my friend Jonas his
brother took me out on a boat show me
this barracks they were claim they're
building into like housing there were
people there now people are living it I
don't know if it was rich like young
hipsters there but they were in between
and the grass in between the barracks
that are now luxury condos I think or
maybe student housing I don't know who
lives there but it was young cool people
out there [ __ ] somebody maybe was
just people who like there's still not
lived in but [ __ ] it's a good place to
go and just [ __ ] chill out by the
beach I'm seeing some cool [ __ ] you guys
I'm doing some fun [ __ ] this trip this
was almost eight weeks and all it'll be
Dublin was cool I'm spending two days in
each of these cities instead of one day
and when I did in Denmark is I took a
ride to Free State Kristiania
which I heard I had some trouble because
they had a shooter there some some guy
shot two cops one on the face and one of
the leg and
was shut down there shut down pusher
Street so like you can't get weed there
anymore the residents took it down the
residents took down the city it wasn't
even that there wasn't even the UH the
police that residents took it down I
think they were like [ __ ] it you brought
violence here apparently the story is so
first they try to blame it on like drugs
and then they child I heard they're
blaming on terrorism like it was a guy
who kind of Isis did it shot two cops
just near Christian or outside
Kristiania and to them his
misunderstanding and nothing to do with
the drugs so they're like let's get the
it's got those pusher Street those Hut's
back in now that was probably just
wishful thinking on a part of a STONER
who had a last experience and Chris
Johanna had a wonderful time there twice
and it just had a [ __ ] amazing time
once with a guy who doesn't smoke really
at all and Bobby Kelly who also doesn't
smoke at all and then of the time
without my friends Jonas is a brother
and that was more of a like oh yeah
let's sit out here and chill listen to
some [ __ ] DJ playing some Bob Marley
and so it was all shut down and I went I
was like well let me see for myself and
it wasn't wasn't there so what happened
was I guess they're saying who's
terrorism but then what I heard from the
inside is no not terrorism it was some
guy transporting the money out of there
the day's money I know I think I doubt
they do a whole day at once they
probably do it hourly that's just like a
business run again it's always the the
dealers who come and take over it's not
just like local hippies its dealers you
know they're there they make money and
drugs in all sorts of stuff they're
[ __ ] gangs who run it so the gangs
run it and they run it pretty safely you
know if you're sitting in one of their
like selling areas they'll be like hey
yeah get out of here or we're doing my
move down come on getting outta here
maybe it's not the best place to sit but
they don't like they're not [ __ ]
about it but their gangs you know they
don't seem like a nice bunch did you
have around your mom but but
you know they're doing it seems like
seemed like the right way till there's
one guy who's taking the money out these
cops random check to see I guess I I
guess there might be laws and how much
like weed you could take out of there
maybe it's that so they don't want
people just like littering the town like
tourists like living the town with like
20 ounces worth so like just keep it
here so maybe they check every once in a
while and they asked his guy who had the
money for the gangs I don't know what
gangs they're like what uh we're gonna
stop you I searched it and the guy just
pulls out a gun and shoots the guy in
the face these two plainclothes officers
which my thought was did you not know
there were police he thought maybe was
being robbed the guy said no way that's
not the guy who told me he said no but I
think he might not have considered that
as a possibility
cuz this guy just not smoke pot so the
guy just shot a cop in the face then
turned to the next guy and go are you a
cop too and then lowered his gun shot
him in the leg and then biked off I
don't know if that meant motorbike or
bicycle there's a lot of bicycles in
Copenhagen I said that jokingly by the
way I know it's Copenhagen I know they
all say wrong we say it right so yeah
and then the guys who run Chris John
yeah they tolerate the drugs they like
[ __ ] it you know it's a basic human
right they talk about stuff like that
where it's like you can go into
anybody's house and just get a glass of
water and walk on it's a basic human
right I might have misunderstood the guy
but it seemed like he was saying that
free straight man Free State Christian
yell its governor ourselves and they
don't mind soft drugs they don't want
coke there they said mushrooms was
borderline they don't mind it but they
don't want violence associated with it
and this was violence and so they tore
down everything and so it's different
but
take a walk around a little bit and I
was like all right I guess uh I guess
walk around Christian yeah look at the
crazy artwork as if I forgot the artwork
was there all the crazy artists to start
of that area that was it abandoned army
base and people just moved in hippies
they started like opening their own
schools with our kids and running [ __ ]
themselves Free State Christian yeah
an anarchist town in our kids kyboots
almost and so you know violence came so
they took it out so I walk around and
look at the crazy art of these crazy
people that are there
he's crazy fun people that are there
they have statues and sculptures of
[ __ ] hands and graffiti all over and
there's a little like a body of water
right there some shops and stuff I
didn't go into any shops really till we
got some tea at this place I like and
then I looked at a guy and he looked
back at me we and he said yes I didn't I
didn't I didn't uh I didn't flinch I
wasn't put off by it or caught off guard
weed yes boom
sold me some and I sat where I used to
sit when I sat last time I was there and
I smoked some weed rolled it up in that
coffee shop bought a skin off the guy
filter rolled it up made a cone for the
first time on my own and then filled up
a cone style I smoked
then I got that [ __ ] riding bug I got
that [ __ ] thinking about [ __ ] in my
head bug it was sunny out the guns were
out I took my guns out all over
Scandinavia was sunny that shirt was
coming off oh you should have seen
people the guy Kaspar took me around it
was like my tour tour manager you kept
going like come on dude I got a picture
of my son's at my guns out in front of
the Nobel Peace Prize Center and Oslo oh
yeah
so I start writing started thinking
about stuff how good I got it
everything's pretty great man like I'm
getting to test my material out in
[ __ ] all over the world
I know deaths especially I gotta do
something [ __ ] weird am i special
this year I'm planning it right now I
know work this out all over the [ __ ]
globe I'm gonna have worked this
material out in in like seven or eight
countries Ireland no oh well America
Canada Ireland UK account Scotland and
England together even though they're two
countries right United Kingdom that
means multiple countries how's that work
Scotland and England let's count it both
oh I forgot where I'm at four or five
Norway Iceland Denmark and where am I
now
Sweden Australia 9 Thailand 10 10 10 10
countries doing this the right way
working with my friends doing a [ __ ]
good special anyway I've got everything
pretty great so then I'm like alright
let's get back in the bike I'm in a good
mood starting to get a little hot right
get a little bit of writing session
going on we've got some stuff thought
about some bits [ __ ] nice perfect
place perfect creative place some dude
playing Bob Marley man so [ __ ] free
feel free outside sitting there in a
park smoking reefer like San Francisco
but
Denmark has got the best weed in Europe
I'm gonna go on the record with that I
haven't heard of other places that could
compete I get that I haven't been
everywhere but I haven't heard the
stories of any place that could compete
with this yes it's better than Amsterdam
all right I don't wanna get into a fight
right so I get back on my bike start
biking around just looking for stuff
some you know Sonny going by that body
of water and that's when I pass those
barracks I started noticing people who
they are mike is so great people like
see no sunbathing other side.now people
somebody thing on this side I'm biking
it's [ __ ] I'm past my European
sunbathers there's a little beachy area
was a sander was a not saying we're not
for like 500 yards and yeah it's his
Beach it was a speech and it's a nude
beach oh my god so it's a new Beach
people are sunbathing naked
I thought about Steve Simone I thought
Steve Simone would be if we were next to
each other just be like oh my god our
new Beach it's a new age keep cool okay
cool cool it's a nude beach don't smile
don't smile it's European ooh peach man
so big deal here it's no big deal which
is a European nude beach there's some
boobs okay yeah whatever man don't put
yeah just biking along nice sunny days
keep in my some things way couple more
boobs oh there's a dick a little bit
sick alright two more boobs baby dick
more boobs never dick
all sorts of boobs nude beach bike
slower bike slower
oh my god Oh get to see some fun [ __ ]
out here so first what I do is I try to
see like some two buildings you're
supposed to see you know all right I saw
that that's cool cool architecture and
then you want to like get in there and
experience some stuff talk to some
people get around start seeing how
people live took of a walk up the
[ __ ] River
in Oslo where do the hipsters areas art
get away from the tourists biking
Copenhagen and I'm assuming the
Netherlands too it's a great way to do
that I'm seeing some crazy [ __ ]
and today's podcasts is all about travel
in the world you guys didn't even
introduce yet it's all about traveling
the globe
my guess is interesting is [ __ ] his name
is Henry Rollins and I first heard of
him when he was still seeing it you
still playing music and then he went on
to do a bunch of [ __ ] acting and then
he does public speaking not public
speaking or storytelling he's what I
like to say Bill Hicks was trying to be
interesting funny I don't know I don't
know I've never seen his show but I have
seen him do my show this is not
happening
new episodes coming out in October by
the way I've seen her do my show and
he's been he was funny as [ __ ] talking
about his first acid trip so [ __ ]
funny I'll link to her on the website
where I linked to all my music and all
that stuff from last week Running of the
Bulls all those pictures on my website
why are you asking me of course you
should go there first Ari the great calm
she's also got tickets to all my shows
like Tampa this weekend at the Tampa
improv Thursday Friday Saturday next
week in Chicago on Thursday 22nd and
then in Rosemont the 23rd and 24th
Rosemont Illinois that's Rose but if you
live in a Rosemont
so if Chicago will be 22nd and then
Rosemont if you live there if you live
in around the city of Rosemont which I
would have heard is not Chicago but it's
actually called Rosemont if you live
near there definitely come out two
nights there Rosemont I'm gonna be in
and then that one day in Denver which is
just my special again if you if you if
you came last time I would advise you
not to come this time it's it's a lot of
the same material it's almost all this
let's just call it all the same material
so
tell your friends who didn't go to for
sure go but like I'm letting you know
I'm just going there because there's
celebration of their anniversary I want
to be a part of it so whatever and then
my special taping November 2nd 3rd 4th
and 5th get tickets now spread the word
in Austin Texas a cap city comedy club
November 2nd to the 5th come on out that
we can come see
Ari Shaffir any of those shows you'll
see the whole [ __ ] thing even for not
the type time they're actually taping
that doesn't matter
just come that weekend bring friends
tell people if you live in Austin let's
make it a part of you guys taping with
all my friends all my friends I'm doing
this the right way all the people I
trust all the people I talk to and I
know I'm doing this the right way from
start to finish
got the lighting guy love Steve Calitri
who's not gonna do another movie he's
gonna do this special with me everybody
that I trust if I can make it look like
the way we want to make it look every
guy's gonna be quiet when they're
filming all the camera guys everything's
[ __ ] doing this the right way anyway
I'm setting it up all right whatever
let's get back to it
so Henry Rollins uh goes all over the
world you guys he does crazy [ __ ] I mean
we're gonna get into it and stuff but
he's a pretty good [ __ ] traveler oh
that's why was that he was a storyteller
yeah yeah yeah you should go see a show
you can get tickets to anything at uh
Henry Rollins com yeah go there his tour
he's gonna be in LA soon for like a
extended run at Largo in December his
podcasts everything go to Henry Rollins
comm to Wells tweet at him if you want
anyway though he's a world
and he goes these place he takes his
camera and he just [ __ ] takes
pictures of [ __ ] he goes to lives a life
he lives the life Henry Rollins on
Twitter also at Henry Rollins if you
want to sell he's cool as [ __ ] and uh so
that's it I met him in Edinburgh he was
gonna be there for a couple shows I
couldn't go he was at the same time as
me on my show my show is on at 6:30
I think his show was seven I couldn't
get to a show I was so excited when I
heard he's gonna be that I could finally
see it
I called his agent it was French with my
age of course at st. places my age I was
a hate get me in I'm going to see that
show
same time DeRosa went he really liked it
anyway but met him in a hotel and uh
Satna in the in the restaurant
downstairs the coffee shop downstairs
and just [ __ ] talk to him about all
these crazy places he's been he lives
life you guys he gets in there he lives
life he sees [ __ ] [ __ ] there are places
I want to go I'm a joiner be on the road
get in there you can find a new
perspective on things that's what he's
doing all the time Henry Rollins that's
what I want to just a new perspective
you know people are just different in
different places I went to some Ironman
competition in Denmark there was right
near my hotel room so an Ironman
competition you know okay you got you
mixed with wanted you to thing and I did
the [ __ ] typical or off excuse me the
authentic whatever country you're in
experience you know like the off okay
for Isis Iceland yeah lent the authentic
Icelandic experience he's getting whale
meat or seal not seal I'm a shark or
puffin but then you talk some locals in
like no we never eat that yeah I had it
twice every when I was younger and
you're like I think this isn't mean what
people are doing that so there's a split
between authentic and also something I
can only do when I'm here you know so
then it's like well maybe it's not
authentic but I want to get some [ __ ]
whale meat while I got the chance
and a zebra burger in um in a Borough
Market of London looking up and down
what to get I don't know what all go
zebra burger y'all how that plays
however one of those do you wanna see
what else we have no no I'm good with
zebra burger that's uh that's that's not
that's not off the list yet let's just
go ahead and get that off honey I can't
imagine any rarer than zebra burger go
ahead put that up you want cheese with
that I don't know man what goes with a
zebra burger so yeah so you mix with
either wines you an authentic thing or
just the local thing so you can't get
rid of the authentic thing first you get
it out of the way you go see the palace
to me anyway you can see the palace you
go see that whatever you eat there
whatever and then you have some local
stuff there's a pizza place where they
put sour cream and and cream cheese on
it in in Iceland alright that's not
authentic do whatever but that's a cool
thing to have there everyone's eating it
let's go to that let's go to that I
remember in peril thick fur for my
relatives left everyone will go out and
get falafel go watch a movie or go get
pizza and watch a movie on Saturday
night after Shibata ended the streeted
flood it's a cool local experience pizza
and a movie so get in there and go see
the local stuff after that that's what I
want to see so um so anyway I'm in
Denmark I saw an Iron Man competition
Idol it was I thought was a soccer game
excuse me I'm gonna change football game
didn't we have when we started American
football didn't we already was a soccer
already in existence
do you Jenna see what I'm saying
dinner Stan what I'm getting at there
was already soccer and there was no
football
there was no American football but there
was soccer in the rest of the world
including the english-speaking world
called it soccer what reason of cause
this year they called it football
football you know the foot what reason
will we have
to not continuing to call it football we
didn't have another sport we were
protecting where we already had that
name you know I mean like we have
baseball everyone calls it baseball
cutter salt
no that's basketball in Hebrew whatever
if another country started a sport where
it was
they throw bases at each other and try
to like gouge each other's eyes out no
no excuse me throw bases at people's
dicks why did I get that baseball
[ __ ] come on
that's wiped right there it was right
there she tried to like you know knock
people down by that balls or whatever
with the bases with his bases if they
started that game they couldn't call it
baseball because he must already be
aware that there is already a baseball
you know I mean if you weren't aware
than fine then obviously call it
baseball but if you were aware then you
got to call it like you know the ball
gouge something like that so we had in
existence European football / soccer we
had that we chose not to call it
football while there was no football in
America we called it soccer and then
years later another sport came up and
that sport we called football we didn't
write there even though we'll hold on
guys before we do this the rest of the
world does call soccer football why
don't we why don't we just name that
football there's our last chance to
catch up because they're about to use
this name for something else that's
barely associated with feet I mean it's
it's I'm telling you you would you would
almost be like they're throwing it in
our face with how little footballs
associated with the feet but they're
caught or that they're gonna call it
that
so I say as president of the American
Soccer Association that we get back
football right now because they're gonna
use it I know it seems like a bluff
because it's I mean it's the RO ball
it's oval ball there's so many different
things they could call it that would be
more apt than football run ball tackle
ball rugby they could call it rugby so
many more things that were closer than
what the word football represents all
over the world and they're saying
they're gonna use it so I say let's just
get it back right now we don't have to
give them soccer we can keep soccer
encases football doesn't catch on let's
just get it no America said dude if I
was president I'd force America into the
[ __ ] catching up no well the name is
soccer now the name for NFL is soccer
national football soccer I go would even
call this soccer football league or
national first
yeah an SL sure they can go NSO no
national football soccer no that's my
work either national soccer league your
choice but the word soccer now for foot
football and we're putting football into
football and they fight me on it people
would still I'm still gonna call
football well you do what you want but
you're kind don't die out you're kind of
died out and the rest of us is smart
once we've left and we're going metric
system - yeah no protests I'm in office
for eight years and I already talked to
my vice president and he said he
guarantees me he's gonna [ __ ] keep it
up if he takes over me that means 16
years [ __ ] 16 years of metric
system - you'll all forget times 10 is
the next thing times 10 is the thing
after that why sometimes 12 times 3 no
I force it on you yeah it ain't a
democracy not for everything yeah sure
you have to vote if we want to go to war
but no not for the metric system we do
the opposite of that didn't we we have
to go to war and we did revolt against
the measure system make him turn our
back anyway so Henry Rollins my guest
today there's a sign and we did it in
Edinburgh there's just sign there at
Edinburgh on a bar near the cow gate I
saw it last year when I went a couple
times I didn't go to Cal gate much was
pretty far up from my venue this year my
venue was right off Cal gate what a
great time Edinburgh was spending a
month with comics from all over the
world could become friendly with them
new people met those guys from last week
if you haven't heard the Running of the
Bulls one it's [ __ ] ridiculous last
week's episode and um yeah she's a great
time
wait what was a semo's you thought my
uber oh yeah I already know so there was
a sign on Cal gate my venue was there I
love to unloved - oh that's why I really
did it I did I brought an american-style
of stand-up comedy to that UK friend
show and I [ __ ] showed them all
showed the ones who were willing to
listen what what comedies like in our
country and what it's like at its
highest levels I think they got it I
think those people got it like guys is
what it can be doesn't have to be these
[ __ ] themes show so spread the word
anyway so on
okay there's this bar I guess I don't
know what the entrances but this is neon
sign red neon sign if I'm remembering
right might be blue I think it's red and
it says not all those who wander are
lost love that sign loved it I forgot
about it and I remembered again when I
went this here not all those who wander
are lost I looked it up junior Tolkien
it's Jared Tolkien who wrote that one of
his poems I guess I'll read it in the
outro but I love that man there's people
out there [ __ ] travel and seeing [ __ ]
going from spot to spot just doing stuff
doesn't that seem like fun just going
out and just doing stuff seeing the
world talking to people getting to know
a new perspective on all sorts of things
do you know weed is very illegal and in
Sweden I met a guy who grows his own
super Silver Haze it's a legitimate
strain it was good it's tough to tell I
hadn't smoked in a few days now I had
Denmark yes good weed then
yeah getting a new perspective not all
those who wander or losses people
wandering around and they're not lost
that's the point is to wander get to get
lost to get just [ __ ] your attention
to your hands dirty man Henry Rollins is
out there doing it he just goes places
you'll hear you'll hear in the episode
he just goes places he's so cool he
lives life so [ __ ] cool listen to his
podcast I think it's just that I think
it's just stories and I think his show
is just that to just see stories he's
put together of the places he's been and
the crazy things he's seen wouldn't that
be cool just to go and be like yeah this
is how it's liking someone so someplace
nobody's been I mean you know Oslo's
fine and stuff but getting rural damn yo
so let's call that episode this it's
called this episode not all those who
wander are lost by the way an Iron Man
competition it's [ __ ] weird
it's [ __ ] that they had to brace up
and down these crazy long thick triple
suicides said the race was on their
hands they'd go up in our hands all the
way down this field look all the way
back not all the way they get to stop
every like I think 10 yards some guys
spot some I like watching people get
[ __ ] lapped by some other Iron Man
dude and that and I started you know
maybe kind of hungry so I went and got
some you know local Danish food by the
way I think once we had the movie Iron
Man I think these competitions that you
just you can't name yourself that
anymore I get it what you're doing is
crazy walking in your hands for [ __ ]
a football field is ridiculous
on track it's not even like grass you
guys it's like trap
you know texture
it's ridiculous but it any what iron man
could do he shoot [ __ ] out of his I mean
get over yourself
I get it what you're doing is very tough
but come on man iron man
why not just say the Superman challenge
then why not just hit Superman challenge
why not just say stupa man if you're
gonna go like oh we're tough is this
like use like you know allegory that's
right word why not just go Superman
obviously you should so just change the
something else tough-guy competition
they have that right I don't know figure
out the WWF did ladies and gentlemen
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank episode 277
man's gossip sure not all those who
wander are lost with Henry Rollins enjoy
yeah I just keep talking here will
you've been in India oh yeah I travel I
travel for work yeah we're here in
Scotland right now
alright so we're traveling we're not
from Scotland obviously so we're here
travelling but we got stages eating as
hours from now whenever I'm not
traveling with a stage I try and travel
as much as I can just with the backpack
and a camera and that kind of travel has
put me on all seven continents and about
almost a hundred countries do you okay
first I did another 100 countries oh do
you go for gigs and then wander off from
there no no a lot of the times I'm doing
extracurricular non non show travel you
know it's exclusively that yeah in that
like last November I was not obligated
to a bunch of people to do a bunch of
things right and so I called my travel
agent months before knowing I had
November free and I said Antarctica
I have November free is at an
interesting time to go and she said
you're very lucky to have November
that's Antarctic spring that's what you
want it's the prime time to go the
Penguins are breeding Wow it's you know
it's when you can get into places that
you can't get in colder times because
they just can't get a ship in there and
so all of November was going to
Argentina going down to a shoe hire the
southernmost city in the world picking
up the boat and going through the Drake
Passage to the an erector insula
dwelling there for a week and then
coming back and then returning via Texas
to LA and so that was that was November
how cool was that there during their
sprint it was plenty cold but not the
coldest I've been to Siberia was the
coldest I think Siberia or northern
Canada
that Canada gets pretty cold yes
ridiculously cold it's cruel it's a
place the most cold it hurts your throat
just to breathe out well you're doing
damage to your throat that's why it
hurts your you're probably killing a the
top layer of skin I mean that kind of
weather
it's it's it's amazing to be an
extremely hot or extremely cold weather
and I've encountered there's a different
kind of Sun kind of spiritual I'm not a
spiritual person but there's a different
kind of Sun in Africa it it just feels
different when it hits you it feels like
it's trying to kill you and that the Sun
like in Egypt or Mali yeah or in the in
the times I've been to Mali like a
little bit out of Timbuktu into the
desert by noon
it's projectile vomit hot like pass out
and it'll kill you by midnight
it's about four degrees above freezing
no way it's one of those and it's really
you have to bring gear for both hot and
cold and you eat the Tuareg men never
the women the doTERRA GERD the people
who live out there those nomads you know
they they follow seasonal that there's
salt
traders they trade things they they move
gold but they are the people of that
region and I go there because I love
their music and they are the toughest
people I've ever encountered besides
people I've encountered in Afghanistan
just because the environment yeah is so
harsh and as a westerner I'm there for
like you know week and a half and it's
insane because by 2:00 p.m. if you don't
find shade or wrap yourself you will get
skin damage you will have a very bad
time to [ __ ] oh yes good yeah
and by night it's a whole other
nightmare and I would watch I go walking
around the campfires at night and watch
the Tuareg men just in their wraps
around the camp they were just kind of
spoon around the campfire and that's how
they stay warm and by day they just move
their head wrap around you know move it
in front of your eyes for the sandstorm
the daily sandstorm move it up move it
down for four
to block the Sun and to bright you
divide the top of your head with like
four inches of cloth as a buffer
they grow their hair out to try to like
help with that I don't know that the the
waited to do it is not undressed but
dress up layering and breathability and
you see people who live in the desert
for real they're like they look like
Lawrence of Arabia their head-to-toe
cotton they're not in shorts because
that'll kill you for all shade yeah you
sweat to stick to you well it the the
cloth wicks it it it pulls sweat away
from you which cools you down
that's evaporation and that's why you a
lot of travel clothes they advertise it
as he quicking it draws moisture away
from you like in Antarctica the clothing
I was instructed to buy they said we
cannot let you on the ship if you don't
have these clothing items because we
need you to be warm enough to be able to
take you off the boat so you can walk
around to meet the Penguins and so you
buy multiple layers of heat-trapping
clothing and it's just like long johns
you know like but with with you know
skillfully made by scientists and you
put like three of these layers on and
you start baking just is this conserving
your heat but then when you're walking
around and being in a boat with wind for
hours at a time you feel basically
neutral not hot not cold but like you
know deal Abul because it's probably
minus something but when I years ago
when I took the trans-siberian Express
from Moscow to Vladivostok you know
every four hours they stopped pick up
people pick up supplies and you can get
out and watch the men smoke and I just
stand outside just to dig the cold and
just trip on it and with a winter's coat
a pair of vans on my feet and your pants
and underwear within three or four
minutes the cold has gone through your
sneakers through your feet and it's like
kind of going up your legs the cold is
incredible and meanwhile the Russian men
who will be getting off the train a day
later do some oil work there in swagger
wears clogs tank tops really get used to
it there they're just tough they're just
like some of the toughest people on the
plan
weatherman said question how do you how
do you like link up with those two Rx
and people like that how do you which
where I got it I met up with some of
them by going to the desert music
festival in 2009 and 2010 or 2008 and
2009 I think I'm forgetting it was a
music festival that had been going for
almost a decade where Mali and bands
would assemble and play and that's I
listened to so many of those bands tart
eat tonari when all these other bands
and so I found the desert festival and I
said well damn it man I've never been to
Mali I'm going yeah and so the first
time I went I just you know booked a
ticket and had the travel agent crank it
up so I left landed in Bamako stayed at
the hotel that was overrun by the ISIS
guys several months ago remember the
people got killed in the hotel yeah in
Bamako that's the hotel at the Radisson
that's where you stayed oh I've stayed
there like a bunch of times and so yeah
and it's in it's in a really harsh
neighborhood it's just like a really bad
you know toughs very sad neighborhood
and the end of the block there's a a
nice hotel like it's kind of wet just
stuck it there anyway you I went from
Bamako up to the name is escaping I'll
remember later based on what just
wondering are they telling you well no
to meet with my guide and so I went from
Bamako to Mopti mo pti to Mukti and I
met up with a guy named Mahmoud who I
traveled with two years in a row he's
Tuareg Mahmud took me in a 4x4 with some
other travelers some Canadians who are
fascinating they vet people who want to
become Canadian though someone says I'm
running from my country because they're
gonna kill me if I go back home this guy
could be African mafia just trying to
escape a murderer and so these people
sit him down and interrogate him trying
to find the lie and if he can pass
through them he might be able to become
a Canadian via amnesty and there's two
of them in the van with me as we went
across Dogon country a four day trip to
get to Timbuktu and their stories were
mind-blowing because they were working
in like Nazaire
and they were taking a holiday didn't
want to go all the way back to Canada so
they went a little ways down the road to
Mali to go to the desert music festival
anyway so I want Overground for four
days and get the Timbuktu and then you
go to s akan for the music festival then
though I went again a year later with
Mahmoud again and went up to niger river
by boat and did it that way so two
different ways to get to Timbuktu which
is where then you get in a 4x4 and you
go across the desert to the festival
site and you damn you live there for
about four or five days under a slab of
camel skin and Around Sundown the
musicians appear and it's music till
about 3:00 in the morning and you know
by the last bands going on you're
standing there freezing like because it
gets that cold Anika oh yeah with your
headlamp you never leave home without a
headline where do you go run back to
your tent or your camel skin then grab
coat and come back tonight yeah you you
I when the Sun Goes Down there's about
an hour where it's like perfect where's
this perfect weather and I just walk
around and take photos because the Sun
turns purple and it's gorgeous Wow and
then it's like a vise around 8 p.m. you
start feeling the grip of the cold and
it starts gently increasing like here it
comes and you put your layers on and you
know you like your four t-shirts and you
starting up and then finally you're you
you're you're really layered up and it's
desert cold there's nothing to hold the
heat damn
and it's I'd be back there now
it got so hairy there that they had to
stop the music festival because of the
Larimar yeah aliens I think some
Italians got kidnapped two groups of
people had problems a one group of
Saudis got kidnapped and maybe a couple
of Italians were killed and two plane
loads of Brits who were coming to the
festival Heathrow wouldn't let him leave
and by the time I got out I said this
too dangerous we're not letting ago yeah
the US government put a travel advisory
so but luckily I was already in Africa
they couldn't stop me but they didn't
America didn't want me to go because of
the the the the hassle and so after that
time
it was too dangerous to put the festival
on and so back to the original point I
go to these places because I'm
interested and I have a high-resolution
Jif file on my computer of the map of
the world and so when I say if I I know
I'm gonna have a month like in March say
I know I've March 2017 off no
responsibilities no responsibilities
there's nothing I can't handle from the
road because I always I'm obligated to
tons of stuff so I don't take my writing
and radio on the road and beam it in
from afar I will pick a landmass and go
from like left to right and so I'll go
okay North Korea China Mongolia Bhutan
Tibet Vietnam which is actually a trip I
made once really yeah and then do you
try to follow that exact path you just
use an outline and be like you know what
I'm staying in Vietnam for a while oh no
no the hotels are booked they'll get all
hardened heart out cuz I got a return to
an obligation so I got to be back 22
days after I left kiss and on day 25 I'm
on set on location on tour something no
and so I have hardens and hard outs -
this is so cool how long you been doing
this stuff like when'd you start doing
this water lost I started doing well
I've had that since I was a kid because
of my mom who was an art nut and she
would save her meager earnings from her
government job and it couldn't have been
much we were solidly middle class and
she would save her money and every few
years she goes okay we got some money
we're gonna go to Italy and Turkey and
this and we're gonna see all these
museums and all these statues and as a
little kid I've been to like Istanbul
and Rome and you know London go to the
National Museum and check out
Shakespeare's handwriting and it's you
know really cool for a little kid to dig
other cultures in Istanbul and the 70s
was nothing like it is now it's very
touristy now I've been there like a
bunch of times and I was there just a
couple years ago on my way back from
Central Asia I was in Uzbekistan and
Turkmenistan Kazakhstan Tajikistan I'd
already been to Kyrgyzstan twice so I
skipped that but I went to Georgia from
there and then on my way back to America
I did like 72 hours in Istanbul and is
now
it's cool but it's very backpacker youth
we're used to be really like a movie you
must have seen that a lot right with
with the cities or countries becoming
like you Western well these become
destinations yeah
and in some ways it's in a lot of ways
it's good looking forward in just my
opinion and now the last haul is in
Katmandu it was like backpacker youth
but I like the idea of young people with
their backpacks leaving home and going
to frickin Nepal like Yusef our NASA and
seeing things and having their minds
blown because maybe I'm hope he changing
in tree-hugging but in my opinion you
can't convince that person to be part of
a war after they go into the world and
see that stuff how are you gonna sell
that kid on the invasion and occupation
of Iraq or that they're different than
we are when you met them and I'm not
different so when their dad goes well
those damn my ringing is all they wanted
like really I've been to Iran they make
me an expert yeah but no one would allow
me to spend money that people just
bought everything for me I had to take
the money I bought a bunch of rial the
money I bought up in Dubai and I had to
I just gave taxi drivers big-ass tips I
had no I still have a big wad of it
which I hope to one day go back to
Tehran and spend it was an amazing place
but our country has a real chip on his
shoulder for Iran they we want to smoke
them and they know that I had
interesting discussions with Iranians
who had been educated at Boston College
okay whose IQs are like you know
stratospheric and they said yeah you
guys want to kill us I go I know I know
I know I know not me but yeah there's a
lot of people who don't dig you because
they don't know if you find yourself
apologizing for your passport no because
my curiosity the fact they like what
when you go to a place like Pakistan you
go all the way out to Islamabad people
just usually just thank you and they'll
say why are you here I said and I have
one a one-liner that always works feel
free to use it I always say why am I
here I'm here to meet you man which is
true I got my name is Henry man what's
happening it always gets a laugh
and I've used that like in convenience
stores in Tehran I've used it on the
streets of Islamabad when you get
recognized when they're just like what's
the white persons over here stand around
long enough someone will come up my
friend are you lost usually trying to be
helpful
are you embassy no journalists hell no
yeah just to travel in why are you here
I'm here to meet you man
what's up and they're like oh well it's
nice to meet you I go hey you can't
understand how cool it is to meet you
man
I flew three days to get here and so I
started doing that kind of travel in the
mid-90s when I would be doing an
interview and someone says well with
rock-and-roll you get to travel I go
well yeah the Australia Japan the
European continent Singapore you know
some cool destinations but I've never
been to Africa and I hated saying that
like what a wimp you know what what a
cop-out so one day I pulled out the map
of Africa I said okay so let's see Egypt
gotta do it
you know Kenya and I just started going
you get all your vaccinations and you
start learning how to travel in Africa
because it's different than traveling
other places really how's Africa
different like Southeast Asia Oh
Southeast Asia just my opinion is
insanely friendly like I'd leave
tomorrow and go I mean there's not one
part of it not to love Africa and I've
been there I'd like 15 times different
parts of the continent again I know
expert but you've got to have your wits
about you like I have a lot of rules I
land and immediately get my bearings I
try and get to the country with some
local currency so I don't have to haggle
with moneychangers because there's no
way they're gonna treat me right right
they go well mr. New York and you have
to hopefully be able to haggle your way
through the customs guys trying not to
take some of your stuff well I have to
take this no that's shaving cream I
really do need that oh wait they just
rather like take it for themselves
yeah okay yeah this is so foreign the
idea but this has happened to
me yeah that was Madagascar like no no
man no no I need I need I need all that
but my friend I'm like no no no it's
it's cool
maybe I'll hook you up on the on the way
out I'll give you all the stuff I'm not
gonna use it like well I'll be waiting
for that my friend yeah I know and so I
get to a hotel and you have to find a
real taxi because everyone with a car
will go my friend
taxi and they could just take you to a
neighborhood and go right get out and
give us all your stuff you don't know
where you're going and that happens
there takes certain parts of Africa you
could happen in Georgia I mean you just
have to have your game on all right I'm
not saying everyone who comes up to you
like you know how are you gonna try and
rip me off but just don't walk around
with your eyes closed because in a lot
of parts of Africa if you're white like
me you are not from there you you it's
not like walking around the streets of
Berlin where you can just pass for
German by just being I'll just keep your
mouth shut
yeah and if you have gear like someone
looks at that bag that's camera gear so
I have a bag made by a company called
think-tank and they make bags that kind
of disguise the fact that it's camera
gear and so what do you got video
cameras are just pictures it just still
I am that I'm not interested in video I
like to take still photography yeah but
you know I've got like a couple of
bodies in a couple of lenses I can't
afford to lose them and you know they
might want to steal those bad I'm not
gonna fight people for it I it's not
what I'm wanting and so you get to the
hotel and immediately look for a place
to find water and if you can find any
crate store they do sell boxes of water
open one up pull one out a lot of them
usually have a government seal like
whiskey crack it and go came by the
whole box to make sure it's not cracked
make sure it's not from the tap right
there's water in some of these places
you don't want to drink it you'll have a
really bad time that's everything
whenever I go to anywhere they're like
do not chance it don't drink the water
never don't worry about it just don't do
it just don't do it and if you can bring
some water with you bring like a couple
of two-liter bottles with you just so
you have ready hydration when you land
but the first thing I do is I lock up my
room
I hit the streets with no gear no camera
gear helping us do no just just no one
to get a bead on me
I just don't not gonna show my hand
because I mean I'm looking for water and
so I go find and I will find like a I'll
buy a case of 12 bottles of water and
drag it with me for days you know big my
backpack becomes like 40 pounds of water
and I walk around and look for good
photo ops find the market place where
the spices are being sold and everyone
gathers to talk it's very colorful and
beautiful and tons of people you can
people watch I get the lay of the land
and the perimeter around the hotel you
know get back to the room before dark
and I get ready for the next day and
then I go out and I walk I just picked
directions and just go or I get a taxi
and go give me five dollars that way the
guy goes why is it what's your objective
just to find the hotel and then wander
back yeah dude that's the most fun yeah
I think you just go down oh no there's
no reason go down this street or that
street so pick one and go yep and I've
been doing that all over and so I
started traveling in an extracurricular
Nam work fashion in 97 my first trip to
Africa which was Kenya Madagascar South
Africa and then the next year was Egypt
yeah and then it was Africa Africa
Africa and then I I've been hit in
Africa for years and I said okay
Southeast Asia
never been to Vietnam had been to
Thailand a bunch just on my way to
Australia on my way back and just like
11 times I've been there for like you
know 72 hours and or shooting a
documentary there and once I it's great
how come I was so much fun back alley uh
kickboxing stuff they have like little
kids fighting oh that I didn't see
walked around the streets out shooting a
documentary said but my nine-to-five was
pretty busy but I'd never been to allow
or Cambodia yeah and so I started
grooving on that went to Vietnam a bunch
of times doing research for some
documentary stuff I wanted to do on
Agent Orange and I tried to sell that
documentary idea to every possible
documentary channel and everyone said
no you're depressed I hate pizza and and
implicates you know people who probably
pay some of their advertising and they
swell Henry you know how this bread is
buttered right get out anyway I love
when you call them I'm not being
completely artistic and they like stop
it
yeah stop it yeah we just go yeah we
both know what's up you know there needs
to be extraterrestrials paranormal or
Yeti otherwise we can't touch it so 90s
into the 2000s I've been traveling in
that way trying to you know any
available time I will just I will go and
I've almost been killed a couple of
times in my life like really really
close like really uncool but that was
America really yeah the rest of the
world has been very friendly me I was in
Iraq once with the USO and there's a
couple of mortars dropped outside a
building we were in but we were in a
building I was you know safe from mortar
so nothing happened obviously they're
not gonna put the talent in harm's way
but then they warned me they said you
know in the next half hour there's gonna
be a mortar attack it's one guy every
day and 20 minutes later you know there
was oh yeah yeah yeah and it was you
know you can taste the adrenaline in the
back of your mouth you know good you can
really is that almost that bitter taste
oh yeah that's adrenaline just comes out
get your whole body that help it right
it reacts to that mortars yeah and it
feels like a like a ghost walked up and
punched you in the sternum the
concussion I mean it's really what I
mean though this concussion the blast
it's like a fist into your breast you
can feel it oh hell yeah it's like
someone that hits you this sucks the air
out real oh yeah it was nothing like it
anyway and I'm sure they meant us no
good with the mortars but beyond that um
the world has been really nice to me
I've spent like weeks in the Middle East
alone going through Islamic countries or
even you go to Indonesia every third
buildings a mosque or going across
Central Asia where it's mosques madrasas
and and
P in Turkmenistan all these countries
have appalling humans rights records but
in Turkmenistan a white guy alone with a
camera there's a lot of soldiers just
like waving at me and just like pointing
at me to turn around because I was too
near a government building and they I'd
say no photo no photo they're just like
you'll go and you do what they say used
to run around and walk elsewhere there's
a lot of it just don't be an idiot
well you're not allowed to take photos
of government buildings or embassies
that's just it that's the law anywhere
and so if you're gonna take the tour of
like government row and look at that
you know the Minister of Finance the
Minister of Transportation buildings and
all that don't bring your camera because
you're gonna put these military guard
guys on alert they're gonna have to come
over and wave their finger they don't
even put them out just like leave your
stuff at home or in the room and then
look at it if you find government
buildings interesting and then grab your
camera and go elsewhere or put it in
your backpack and just never check that
camera otherwise you're gonna come over
and you know give you a speed you must
get cuz I get it I don't travel as much
as you but I'd like to go see show ya
you must get people from not here
America going like dude that's too
dangerous don't do that oh all the time
what do you tell them well I told them I
can't advise them to do what they're
gonna do with their life
but I I tell them I personally can't
live being afraid of the earth and being
afraid of the world and being afraid of
people it's not how I live in Georgia be
bush you know I went to every country I
went to all three countries of the axis
of evil yeah yeah cuz he saw what was
going on uh yeah he said you know don't
go there you know paralyzers you know
full fear know what well no I refuse and
I'm not a tough guy really and I'm not
looking for a fight and I'm not you know
looking to run for my life I just
refused to fear the world because my
experience has been I was in Pakistan
when Bhutto was assassinated I mean that
was intense
ii died the second or third day I was
there the Islam ababbas columns of smoke
she got killed like four miles from my
hotel near the airport in Rawalpindi
when was that how long was uh
seven okay I just finished a film in
America and the next day I wrapped out
and left for Islamabad and like 48 hours
into that and I was downtown every day
in the blue district where the shopping
is this hanging out fool a fooling with
people men you know you'll talk to women
you're introduced maybe but men will
talk to you and my friend why are you
here I'm here to meet you what's
happening and yeah soon you're talking
about the weather and around sundown the
sky turns purple and like 80 million
mosquitoes come out see if you have a
path back to your room but it's not the
danger that made me go back was clouds
of mosquitoes literally they're like
here they come and you Jam back and then
two nights in I returned to the room put
on al Jazeera and Bhutto's been
assassinated and I look at the newscast
I look at the sky oh wait a minute this
is real time Wow and by the next morning
the hotel lobby is full of every embassy
is emptied into our hotel so there's
cranky kids like in their pajamas people
on big satellite phones scary security
like men in suits with Uzis bulges I
mean like hardcore security like license
to kill you right now for a frown and
Reuters so you know news 8 news carriers
everyone at the Tsarina hotel and so I
left the hotel yeah this is smoke
everywhere and there's the front lobby
as the gate rather is festooned with
soldiers because if you got half of the
embassies are jammed up in there so
they're protecting you know the American
consulate or whoever and they said sir
please go back to your room I go well is
it illegal for me to walk on the streets
I said no but you know it's not a smart
idea I said yeah I know so I'll see you
guys later or maybe I won't and then way
all right man
and I I stayed outside until the bugs I
stayed outside all day
was it chaos out there yeah was it was
it weather people being killed and shot
that's no no no no there's just men
weeping it was all men and boys boys
lighting things on fire
breaking stuff and men hugging each
other and weeping and asking if I was
lost and if I was okay
we've been because their leader got
killed yeah because if they had an
assassination in there
well she was she was the presumptive I
mean she was probably going to win and
and so uh I'm forgetting the name of the
president who was there at the time I
should know this stuff anyway so I stood
outside and well I marched in a March
these men with like two-by-fours are all
pumping their fists I just jumped in
with him and we're like yeah marching to
a mosque and suddenly their own Rose
kneeling to pray and I kind of tiptoe
through the rows and get out of the way
of their prayer but I stayed out until
the evening and that's when all the
women came out and it was men and women
on the streets at sundown and I stayed
until the bugs you know the mosquitoes
and I went that was my room and those
soldiers like where have you been all
day I said on the streets man over there
experience and [ __ ] yeah seeing things
and I was in I was in Katmandu on the
day of their big parliamentary elections
all's on my way to Bhutan and everywhere
there's people on the streets and so I
leave the hotel with my camera and I'm
wandering through people with all these
little billets because there's like 80
people running for each seat and then
was throwing the bill that's up in the
air so it's a bunch of people and people
start grabbing me right by my arm not in
a scary way they're like journalists
journalists I'm like no no no traveller
traveller and they they're like come no
cameras like this and so they're
pointing like take a photo of that take
a photo of that and they're pushing me
to the front of like rings of people
where people are dancing and he said
photos take photos I what okay and so it
took photos of people dancing and
playing instruments and holding up you
know like yay we're voting everyone's
very happy at first votes no it's it
well I found out this the story it kind
of has to go on so I'm there until I
lost light and everyone's like grab me
like you know no photo that they're like
asking me to photo stuff I'm like sure
and I'm getting great photos I'll be in
my next photo book and so I get back to
when it's dark I get back to my room and
I type elections Katmandu and the press
had been kicked out at like Oh 830 hours
no cameras allowed
the government kicked out the press I
wandered in after the president kicked
out for hours and so I sent my I
developed some photos like you know
photoshopped and made him nice and sent
them to my manager and he sent them to
Getty an AP because I was one of the
only people with a camera in there at
all just cuz I was a tourist I just
wandered in through like some side
street Wow hours after the press have
been kicked out I think that's so crazy
scoop just cuz I was there on the right
day yeah I was also in Katmandu a year
before when the Communist Party of Nepal
staged a countrywide strike and I'm
outside with people waving these massive
hammer and sickle flags and yelling
through megaphones and I'm just
wandering around no one paid attention
to me and I wander back to the hotel the
yak and Yeti hotel that's the name of
the place and I was in the executive
floor to that fashion Internet and the
the guy in the team room was always
trying to get me to have a cup of tea so
that evening I went in he said where
have you been my friend I said I've been
out on the streets he said do you know
what's happening today in Nepal I said
well there was a bunch of communist
flags out there they said I said I
notice that there's no vehicles on the
street so I guess it's a holiday is it
no that was the Communist Party
threatening to torch any vehicle on the
street he said I couldn't even ride my
motorbike here I had to walk like five
miles to get here this is it's a
national strike what were you doing
outside I don't know man wandering
around they said there's been like four
people killed today I'm like well no one
looked at me the only people who gave me
a hard look with the guards in front of
the American Embassy who are like coded
for bear but you ever do the math and
like yeah four people killed out of a
million or whatever it is five hundred
thousand that's not that many yeah but
you know the odds are it's not gonna get
- yeah well you know it's so scary the
world is a trippy place but you know
we're Americans right yeah we have
unenviable homicide rates that we look
at all the time always that were those
I've been on tour most of this year this
is my sixth time to Europe this year
crazy the my ass looks like an economy
plane seat but yeah at one point the
woman who manages me she sent me a photo
of the bottom of my street with like
young tons of cops she said they just
shot a guy like four doors down from
your place and like okay I think he's
breaking in somewhere and they're people
in Psalm and called the cops the cops
came up and he like was going for a
weapon or school you moved his hand and
they just you know where was this this
is in Hollywood yeah right off Hollywood
Boulevard
and so I got this big blurry cell phone
photo of fly cops and cop cars in tape
and I'm like I know that stop sign wait
a minute
and so we Americans we live in an
environment where you know wrong wrong
parking lot wrong Walmart on the wrong
night yeah and it could be everything
from the beltway's shooter does some guy
who's had too many who doesn't like your
Obama sticker on your car who wants to
have a word with you yeah oh you're from
Potomac right I lived in Washington DC
I'm from Cairo oh cool but you know I
mean yeah as an American brand up for
grabs
yeah and there's no neighborhood that's
that safe in that you know unless you
live in a gated community with Rod
Stewart but beyond that you gotta go to
the supermarket at some point and once
you're out you're out there and that
Beltway shooter was random yeah there's
no like now is uh that was pretty scary
I was in DC like five days before that
broke out that's where I come from so
whenever I can I go visit and I was
there visiting the old neighborhood and
days later I was something for someone
doing some am talk radio thing and that
was the main topic because you know the
reports are coming in like you know like
met Michaels whatever that that Hardware
art store some was killed in that
parking lot like cuz they were trying to
tie it together like how would these
links and so was like not just a guy
driving around is awful watching that
one sheriff guy who is kind of in charge
of you know because he was just like
sweating bullets trying to figure out
the mo of these those those two guys but
anyway um
travel to me it's it's necessary for me
it informs a good part of what I talk
about on stage yeah it informs what goes
into my camera it informs all the travel
books that I write I write I own a
publishing company so I sleep with the
owner every night so I can publish
anything I want I publish travel books
and I publish my my travels with photos
and the photos are everything from
record stores in Moscow to the pyramids
you know whatever
I remember listen to you once I think
I'm KCRW I guess it was but you were
just like hey here's a record I found
randomly and I don't even know where yea
and cool song I want to play it for you
we're gonna find that anywhere else
right and me and my road manager Ward
he's he and I have been traveling the
world together
I don't like 12 years now thankfully
we're both record maniacs and so Ward is
always on it he's got that record store
finder app so we get to get to any tally
all right mate you go to the gym I'm
gonna find this record store he's a big
Australian guy and I always go hit the
gym and I come back his heart alright
I've been to two they're great
we got a runner we're going and we just
hit the record store and then we go to
sound check and so we're in record
stores almost every day on tour from
zero to two stores a day yeah just
trying to find drums all the time and we
were just in Dusseldorf and we had more
of the most amazing record store days in
years why Dusseldorf is where Kraftwerk
is from oh yeah it's where some of the
first what they call krautrock I despise
that I call it cosmic music some of the
first cosmic music records or shows were
done and so we're a slow boy records and
he's a slow boys - guys guntur and andre
us they're a vendor on discogs and i buy
stuff from them all the time because
they deal in really weird eclectic von
stuff which i listen to a lot of and so
Ward said you know slow boy I go yeah
the discogs he goes no it's also a store
I've called them their clothes cuz
they're moving but they're gonna open
the store for us and we had a day off to
drive to Holland so he goes we're going
over there at noon and so and I meet
these guys have been ordering stuff from
couldn't have been nicer and we're
finding
records we're just pulling it's gonna be
a great day and more goes come over and
look at this and they have these a row
of framed posters and there is a promo
poster for the first new album from like
1971 okay I'm like that so I'm a poster
fanatic there's a poster for a cluster
Kraftwerk gig from like 1970s one or two
or whatever and then there's a promo
poster for the first cluster album and
then there's a gig poster for acting you
know the cosmic music explosion
tangerine dream Konrad schnitzel Erik
these godfathers of cosmic music and
these are a ridge I said are those real
because something that old you just
don't see anywhere as it are those real
and I said yeah I said how did you get
those because those were hen's teeth
those are so rare he said well we got
the NOI poster from Klaus dinger from
Noi he lives in town he found them in
one of his store spaces the cluster
poster woodcut was found at the home of
Conrad Schnitzler the guy from the band
under his couch his wife found a pill of
the left over a pile of them and we
convinced her to sell them to us and we
got these other I forget how he got the
other two posters maybe from maybe Klaus
dinger and I said okay here's a stupid
question do you have any for sale only
what Oh looking - I said oh I'd like to
talk to you about half these are pulling
open poster drawers and they had several
of the cluster poster one of the craft
work cluster multiples of the other -
and I just picked out the best-looking
versions and some others seriously rare
30 plus year old punk rock gig posters
and we they gave me a very good deal we
rolled them up into poster big-ass
poster tubes
road manager ward he split the other day
out of Germany so he took them over to
my office I'll be back in LA on Monday
I'm going right to the business trip you
just found him yeah I was like what
eight days ago
and we walked out of there because he
bought one of the cluster promo posters
which these are insanely rare hand
screened on paper you blow through it a
hole punched through is so old it's like
1971 sitting under a couch the
provenance is so cool
earlier this year in January we have the
afternoon before the show in Moscow and
so we have a on the ground guide who
knows we want record stores he goes I
got the record store of all record
stores we go into the Soviet bloc and he
goes fellas
get ready we go in some dingy door with
like a cutout record over the door like
ok this is gonna be awful walk down some
stairs and go into basically a place
that looks like the Library of Congress
and it is full of Records and we're like
oh no sound check a hundred and forty
eight thousand records this guy has and
we're like ok and I just it was so big I
just went to section so I could find ok
look they have a Joy Division section
every bootleg I had and like 10 I didn't
so I said ok getting these road manager
award is in two extraordinarily rare
prog and avant stuff stuff that I don't
even I can't even pronounce huh I hear
him four aisles over going like I've
been looking for this for like 15 years
I've never I have an mp3 of the album I
never thought I'd be looking at this it
was sitting on top of a stack of Records
luckily for the owner of the record
store he knows what he has and it wasn't
a cheap record but Ward bought it I said
war you're never gonna see it again just
just buy it how much of records like
that how many how much were they that
was 300 bucks ok which is cheap because
he could put it on eBay right now and
another fan of that record would just
buy them for five and so um so he bought
it he said I said you only live once man
you know you got to do it he said yeah
you're right
dreams were threats I said through the
throwdown dude and I came out of there
with a bunch of Records and he came out
with a few
and we're on our next tour of Russia
we're plugging in one or two days off in
Moscow just so we can so go there oh
yeah no we're gonna be there at opening
till closing because there's so much to
check out I mean there was literally
aisles and boxes and most of its data
based I mean it was incredible and I've
never heard of this store before and
through a translator I asked the owner I
said are you buying like entire
collections and libraries and he said
yeah I said but you have like the new
you know this record or that record you
know whatever and he said yeah so I said
so you're getting records from England
and Germany goes oh yeah yeah there's no
trade band I mean what getting records
from every distributor in Germany who
gets new stuff now
oh yeah we're like the new Adele record
or what really no yeah all of that and
the Arctic Monkeys whatever it was like
going to Tower Records on steroids
because he also had blues and jazz
records that I have in my collection
because I bought him a hundred years ago
for cheap but he had him like how are
you finding this Lightning's record I've
seen like two of these in my life he's a
strug hey you know and so this is why I
travel to go hit a record store in
Riyadh Saudi Arabia I went to three in
Riyadh and found Omar Suleiman records
I've never heard seen before that might
be who it was was Omar Suleiman it might
be who was your like record so I bought
the thing in Riyadh in Saudi Arabia an
amazing Record Store Day in Saudi Arabia
found a bunch of Omar Suleiman yeah
from Syria anyway you ever find any cool
old Black Flag stuff and you were like
oh yeah I remember this I saw bootleg
two times I saw a bootleg in Moscow
which I'd never seen before
but I saw a we went into a small studio
once in Venice in 1984 did a full set
miked and mixed 16 track for a radio
broadcast that never happened I have
never heard the this session it was on
CD in Japan Wow yes almost the studio
owner had a rough mix cassette how'd you
do next year memory of it
oh I never I've never played it but I
bought it
III went oh so of course as a record
store neighborhood in Tokyo Shinjuku and
like every third stores a record store
and whenever I'm their day off all day
in Shinjuku and you come out with an
extra suitcase worth of bootlegs like
the entire 1974 King Crimson tour every
damn shows in the store so you just pick
out oh yeah Bremen Berlin Paris
there's stores that are just dedicated
it's like only Dylan one star is nothing
but Zeppelin and like Guns & Roses and
they just like super highly specialized
all mod stuff tons like all metal stores
or like all punk rock it's one of the
many reasons I travel I travel to
understand what globalization is doing
to the world what global climate change
is doing to the world what the World
Bank and the International Monetary Fund
is doing to the world was American trade
policy's doing to the world what have
you saying but here's what I noticed
when somebody asked me once it was like
what do they think of in these small
places and you know in Asia or wherever
were to think of America and my answers
usually they don't they don't think
about it one way or the other
well the opinions I've always gotten is
we love you we love you or Decker or
they they love them some Schwarzenegger
but what I it's not what people have
said to me it's what I've seen like in
pnom pen to see the gap factory and when
Tom was in to Phnom Penh and I meet
there's two western women in the lobby
the hotel they recognize me and they
said hey Henry Rollins what are you
doing here I said I'm going to tool
slang and changuk the killing fields to
go check all that out which I did which
was really severe self oh yeah yeah yeah
man there's bones and clothes coming out
of the ground - yeah it's really sad I
spent all day just you know picking up
teeth and buttons and just you know
tripping on all that and I said I'm just
here you know with my camera just
checking things out what are you all
doing here
and they said we work for Levi Strauss
and I said let me remember
the most American garment no longer has
it pulled up all of its and I hate
Stefan all memorize you pull up your
factories here here and here and you the
most American garment is no longer made
in America right they said well our
super upper end jeans are but yes
everything else went to other countries
you are correct
and a bunch of Americans lost jobs nice
to talk about it on stage so I said so I
guess the Levi's plant landed here and
they said yes not as it's yeah well a
lot of clothes get made in Southeast
Asia you know that like through the loom
and whatever that's where a lot of
things in the world get made is these
other countries that's why you can buy
them for a dollar fifty at Walmart
because someone's getting a dollar fifty
a year to work there right and so I said
so okay what are you doing here in
Panama Penn ago we inspect every fiscal
quarter we are here to go to the Levi
Strauss plant because the company heads
do not want anyone treated badly they
want so we make sure there's ventilation
bathroom breaks that no one is working
pregnant that no one's in pain and our
company is really all about that look
yeah of course we're trying to please
the stockholders whatever but we're not
interested in a sweatshop right so we
are here every three months on
everyone's case to make sure everyone is
going by the book I said okay I'll give
you a pass on that but all right that's
the effects of of globalization you'll
go to some small village in you know in
like Sri Lanka or parts of India and
you'll see some kid I saw some kid with
his Shepard Fairey t-shirt on Hanah with
the artwork that Shepard did for the Led
Zeppelin best of records celebration
with the big Zeppelin okay and I saw the
there's a little kid on my hey man
alright let's settle in and he kind of
looked up and he doesn't know what I'm
talking about
and it's a cool shirt shirt but it was
just in a pallet of shirts that got sent
by some NGO to that part of the world
and the kid they just it fit him he put
it on
on that same trip I was somewhere and
saw a kid with a slayer shirt on teenage
come on all right a slayer shirt in a
dusty village I want slayer all right
the guy went oh this what Slayer I know
it's the band oh okay this is my sleeves
just a shirt all right on and you went I
was in Haiti and I volunteered to
deliver some croc shoes to some orphans
up up in the mountains and so I got out
of port-au-prince and we went there with
a bunch of these Crocs shoes to a
village of orphans and the kids put the
croc shoes on as soon as the shoes come
out of the boxes they all gather
together for the photo because every
time they get something they know they
have to gather together for the so the
NGO rep can take the photo to put in the
brochure so the NGO can get more money
meanwhile many of the NGO
representatives at the hotel I was an
importer prints
white wine lunches and whenever I'd be
in the hotel lobby they're always in the
restaurant of the bar and I asked the
guy who is showing me around town Jimmy
I rented a car you know with the car
drivers I can get into neighborhoods and
get out with a local so I said Jimmy
this morning I saw those people eating
eggs benedict we're back for lunch I was
by Jimmy lunch just by noon
port-au-prince is like sweltering you
know hot summer hell and so I said let's
go get some chow man and my treat and
those same people are drinking white
wine and having a big lunch and then
they're roaring with laughter drunk at
the bar that night so I said I never see
them outside isn't that like World
Vision and all those NGOs he said yeah
here's the deal and I found this out I
went to all these tent cities and had
Jimmy translate for me and I said so who
are the good guys and everyone said
Doctors Without Borders World Food
Program I said who are the bad guys and
everyone said World Vision every village
every tent city hated World Vision and
I'm not here to put him down I have no
idea what they get up to and I said so
why I said they come
to our ten-city they make a you know
they bring us like you know 50,000
gallons of water in some bladder which
is now dilapidated and flat they we do
the photo-op and then they leave but
they come into our country with X amount
of money they spend 10% of X and they
get their salaries and they eat and then
they leave with a ton of the money
and these people are salaried and then
they just put photos into the brochure
of us with the water and they get more
money but when they come here most of
the money leads it comes in with them
but it goes back they give us a little
bit but they're making money it's a scam
just a photo-op he's a photo they did
that in the with the Red Cross and the
camps in Germany where they painted them
all white and said look it's not that
bad
got the pictures then got out of there
and went back to here you go and so I've
been in countries where in the morning
I'm in the breakfast room with NGOs
talking shop around me like where have
you been I've just been in Romania for
two months all what a crap rotation I
was there last year real [ __ ] show and
these guys are just tough talking that
was in Burma I was in Rangoon and I was
on my way up to Mandalay and you just
hear him talking shop my god what's the
better gig all you gotta go and get you
know and they're just kind of
third-world hacks they do third-world
porn poverty porn and the drawing a
salary and what people said to me in
every tent city in port-au-prince was
it's not what you think it is I mean
we're screwed we're in need and they
give us some aid because I would go
there every day with Jimmy and say okay
is there something I can do for you I
got like I got a little bit of money I
got a car I can't bring you 150 thousand
gallons of water and usually they would
say we want soap and soccer balls soap
so we can do the washing and soccer
balls for the kids so me and Jimmy would
go to stores and I clean him out with 4
cent bars of soap and buy every soccer
ball they had and you give it to the one
liter of there's always the leader of
the pack the one main alpha and you give
him to him he lines everyone up and he
hands everything out and he tells you to
get out or you make a cash contribution
she goes okay you've made merit and he
gotta go these two are cool and then you
get to take photos of anything you want
because you've paid off you've gotten in
yeah well you made merit right as the
Buddhists say made merit I like that
term yeah that's a Buddhist term I heard
at one point in Burma actually making
merit like paying you dues and so when
you see what is said on all of those
this this is Pepe Pepe's lonely and he's
hungry that guy is always on a 4:00 in
the morning you can help Pepe and his
wonderful sister Claudia and they bring
in The Crying girl uh-huh
by giving this money now this child
needs you and the kid starts crying the
sepia tones I mean yeah and it's you the
kids are adorable and you know it's
awful when you feel bad because you're a
nice person and they're hungry you you
what I've learned is you can't be
completely sure where all that money
goes and that's what travel has informed
me that the world is an extraordinarily
brutal place yet humans with people with
nothing and you see that a lot in Africa
people would like you know a t-shirt and
a stick I mean they there's so it's
tough yeah
and or like in South Sudan you know
they've had a war with the North for how
many years and I was in one village
where there's these lumps in the
cornfield and they're growing corn on
the corpses of dead northern soldiers
you know with us an ex-soldier from the
South Sudanese Liberation Army and he
looked down at the dirt and pulled and
he pulled a dead soldiers t-shirt out of
the dirt and shook it in front of my
face and threw it down and disgust and
walked away from me because he had
actually been fighting there like in
1996 or 99 that's what he took me there
to show you the field he said my friend
died my best friend died underneath that
tree he said I was standing here
shooting this way throwing my ammo
canisters behind me and I said would
those be your ammo canisters right there
and he goes yep those are them they're
still there Wow and then the local
farmers he was Dinka they were Dinka and
they came up and said we want to show
your your Western friend our corn
they're very proud of it so I said
absolutely yes sir I went we checked out
the corn I said let me let me take a big
guess
about what these lumps are were the
corns growing big I said uh graveyard
and said yeah and that's when this
soldier whose name I'm not allowed to
give out will call him George that's
when George found something in the dirt
and pulled out the t-shirt and stuck it
in my face and said the north and threw
it down and walked South hatred for them
well they were trying to yeah yeah yeah
his family and his stories will peel the
paint off your car at one point him and
his fellow child soldiers were so hungry
they were eating the not so awful parts
of a dead hippo just scooping out the
parts that weren't you know two maggot
filled and eating it damn if they had to
put something in their stomach
damn he's still a war going on you were
there no but you walked through it
they're right about the rather elections
I so I took photos of that but you look
down on the ground and there's like
shell casings everywhere there's like
expended bullets and we're you know but
you know bullets you know real bullets
that just went through something and on
the ground I came back with a fistful of
him would you know when you go on these
trips how do you how do you stay away
from well you're not much of a Boozer
are you normal okay how do you stay away
from booze culture and still see the
things you want to see is it just go to
bed at night or is it like oh no at my
normal say I'm in Hanoi okay I am out
all day walking the streets digging
you're meeting people any museum and
learn about the war you know whatever
Hanoi is fascinating us the Christmas
bombings we're Nixon and Kissinger
bombed Vietnam it to the negotiation
table and it's a it's a very interesting
city to learn some Vietnam War history
or the American wars they call it there
see it's in the other side yeah oh yeah
no no get to get the Vietnam War from
the Vietnam perspective I've been there
three times to do that and it is really
worthwhile
it's heavy and the people couldn't be
nicer but they're very happy to tell you
how hard you got your ass kicked
proof of which is you know the hammer
and sickle Flags everywhere and every
third building is a poster of Ho Chi
Minh
every wall so didn't look like America
one that persuasively to me at least I'm
not trying to get in a bar fight in
Montana but uh what was I sing my booze
culture yes so I'll be out all day
sweating you know getting my photos
taking notes I go back in the late
afternoon get in my workout shower up
eat and the rest of the evening is spent
taking my notes and writing things up I
write for the LA Weekly so I owe them
article once a week I owe Rolling Stone
Australia an article once a month and I
get asked it to write I just wrote a
thing for the fringe for The Guardian
and I owe an article to the Australian
like I got to get on that this weekend
and so at night I just write up the
notes from the day and write in my
journal and so the rest of the evening
is in the hotel cafe or bar where the a
cup of coffee writing or listening to
music in writing okay it's I never drink
some nights in Southeast Asia I like
going out at night just because it's
cool
temperature-wise t-shirt and still
sweater yeah it's there's a whole
nightlife at nighttime in some African
cities is cool like Morocco like
Casablanca at night is really cool where
I wouldn't go out in in in like Nairobi
at night yeah because you might be
rolling the dice night time in Cairo is
intense it's a really to wander the
streets yeah okay
no businesses are open other than
computing stores gas stations and you
know some restaurants if you're in a
hotel neighborhood t-shirt vendors you
know for Westerners like in Cairo it's
all about the pyramids and a hotel and
an airport like Vegas so you know
there's a you can see the pyramids from
almost any hotel because it's all about
getting you there getting you to the
Giza pyramids and getting you to the
gift shop it is what it is the rest of
the rest of its a sand and the Nile that
part of Egypt is super wide it's amazing
so I I will go out at night and walk
around for a while and find a cool place
to sit buy a bottle of tea like in
Thailand I'm always outside at night
just walking around or anywhere in
Southeast Asia I'm always outside for
like an hour at night and then I go back
do my notes and so my my trips are a lot
of photography a lot of notes and
writing and museums and galleries and
trying to get information I'll rent a a
guide for two days and go okay every
museum and give me all the Intel I
should know yeah and what I'm usually
able to do is in an interesting country
like in Ulaanbaatar Mongolia
I rented a woman I had a tour guide for
two days and she liked to you know noon
to five experiences and by day two I had
broken her I break them all what a man
the trustor I just need the interesting
information okay your government has
some very interesting things said about
it on the Internet I want to know more
well sir I'm really not I can't I go I
know but it's Henry and you know me I've
made you laugh and so I want some deeper
information and in Mongolia this one
woman hooked me up with a guy from a
group who is trying to push the
government over and he said I she said I
told this guy about you yesterday she
said I've never met anyone like you you
they broke the mold on you Henry and you
got questions he has answers so we're
gonna go out way out of town to like a
spy outlaw bar
we're like near new wells go he's gonna
he doesn't speak English
I'm gonna translate and you're free to
take notes but you can't take photos I
said okay and i sat with this guy for
three and a half hours pen and paper
yeah you know I took notes on their
covert operate you know the stuff
they've been doing you know pushing this
over pushing that over because their
country's being sold out for mineral
rights and I learned some amazing stuff
what are they trying to do how does our
planet is selling off their like copper
LED titanium all these mineral rights
for a song
and this group is trying to unseat that
government and bring it back to the
people and they are a radical group
they're not killing but they are
lighting stuff on fire and I said okay
no photos and no names and we just shook
and and by like day three and lhasa
tibet i broken my guide and i said she
was she she said my grandmother says
that you would be you'd make a very good
buddhist she she wants to meet you and
make you food and give you many
blessings and i said well can we go to
your house i can meet your grudges no
westerners aren't allowed because the
Chinese don't want Westerners to see how
we live I said okay I need you to tell
me real stuff and she owes okay I'm
going to tell you she whenever she
wanted to give a word emphasis she would
make it plural so she I'm gonna tell you
many's mennies things and she said in in
Hmong in tibet we are many many SADS
many SADS
which just killed me because so such a
beautiful use of english many SADS i
said well the dalai lama come back and
she said no he'll never see almost are
crying she's he'll never come back we
have many sets and that the chinese are
killing us the killing killing to back
killing tibet and we would sit somewhere
she goes okay that's an undercover cop
there's another one there's another one
there's another one you can start to
pick him out they have aviator shades on
and they stand by all the flagpoles i go
why are they by the flagpoles says to
make sure a radical doesn't shimmy up
the pole and tear down the flag and put
up a Tibetan flag well and she said
we're being killed
we're being were being killed and
they're not allowed to tell me this
stuff and almost any tour guide in these
countries like in Turkmenistan I broke
that woman like an hour because she was
a young University student I said okay
she wants to talk yeah and I had the
right questions we're in a restaurant I
said okay those Sopranos looking dudes
who just got out of the SUV they're
mafia right she's would you shut up and
they all looked up hahaha take that as a
yes I said what are they moving they
said heroin opium because they're on the
hood of Afghanistan
I said she said for the locals you'll
just get killed for doing dope but the
president gets you know everyone knows
dope is moving through this country and
meanwhile they let the soldiers and the
Afghans shoot each other at the border
for the appearances of like
righteousness but the drugs are moving
and it's all good to go and it's like
Russian mafia
I forget Serb I don't know it's like you
know heart and these guys were scary and
you can tell they're in there all I
don't want to look around or talk I
don't know they come in looking like you
know big leather jackets loose pants and
they come out of a big SUV that's open
by some young guy and they all come walk
in they sit down and like the bottle
hits the table and you know a little
hard you're like I've been to brush up
punchy you know you've you recognize
these knuckleheads like it is what it is
but it's with mafia where they just
can't dress cool why can't they just
have some fashion sense do what they
want you know like when I was in Moscow
the first time when the Russian mafia
was really rocking and rolling it was a
mafia hotel we're in a mafia gig we did
and they they parked their new Range
Rovers on the sidewalk they leave the
sticker in the window so you know it's
new and they just parked on the sidewalk
cuz it's their town yeah cops are bought
off militaries bought off to him yeah it
was radical I've been there a bunch of
times now but the first time was the
most interesting because the Mafia were
just like in like full swing then
eventually they started shooting each
other up and the smart ones when
corporate they bought airports and
hotels MTV whatever the dome was estate
on the street just kept shooting each
other you know bouncing well the Wild
West guys just all knocked each other
out the smart ones went into the
infrastructure yeah that's like Michael
Corleone II you know he went corporate
and the smart ones went corporate
they're probably you know owning hotel
chains in Russia now they're over
wealthy but they they went straight yeah
that's what's happened to Vegas right
what Vegas was like yeah like let's just
actually make money off tourists yeah
and with a guy like Putin in office and
you're mafia and you're acting out you
will get killed and they all knew it
went well I think when he came to town
they all went okay
you know fun under Yeltsin but under
Putin we're all gonna die to him and
he'll yell gleefully kill us all and
yeah well he's he's the worst I had a
woman in Kazakhstan a couple of years
ago defend Vladimir Putin to me yeah and
I just took it oh my god Wow okay under
what she said we bet he's better than
Yeltsin cuz he also is just a drunk and
Russians love him I'm like okay I go
what about the girls in [ __ ] Riot they
got what they deserved
Wow come on okay I still have to get out
of the country so you learn when to go
smooth like when you're in North Korea
and you're taking the tour and they tell
you how Kim il-sung invented electricity
and the solar system these amazing fun
facts and you just take it cuz you got
to get by we're gonna do argue I'm
getting trouble you gotta get back to
Beijing
that's that subjective one is you got to
get acid don't argue you know do you
talk to expats these places the people
have lived there for a fierce I've
talked to expats in in the UAE well I
can do buy-in
Wow Middle East I've talked to some oil
executive types you know work for Saudi
Aramco and that's because the diplomat
buddy of mine got me to Riyadh because I
met him in Cairo years ago and I was
kept in touch with him and him and his
wife they are foreign service and they
rotate every two years to a different
insane location and they wrote me from
Riyadh and said hey you want to visit us
in Riyadh we'll get you a family visa
I'm like yeah well yeah because it's
really hard to get there as a citizen
like you'd have a insanely hard time
getting there in fact I don't think you
could do it we need to be like oil
person or diplomat or friend or relative
of and that's how I got in in fact the
guy who got me my visa he's we've never
seen one of these in this building it's
it's like second from the top who do you
know I said well a friend of mine is
like is it diplomatic that's how you get
this he said we knew you must have been
somebody because we've never issued one
of these we've seen the but we've never
issued one this was in LA oh yeah
do you uh when you ride these places do
you ever do you ever have flings no
never no never like week-long romances
or anything no I've been hit on I got
hit on by where was I I was in India and
a girl from somewhere met me in the
breakfast room and just basically said
look yeah here's what we can do and I
said no that's that's cool
come on you know she was pretty but it
just wasn't it just didn't seem like the
right thing to do but because no you
don't know what come out with it
actually Oz and with social networking
being what it is I get a lot of offers
for fun
hello but I'm 55 and a half you know
it'd be a little silly but that doesn't
stop men and women we're very perfect
apart from from thank you but that
doesn't stop men and women from saying
hey you know age appropriate age
inappropriate I get all kinds of off
yeah that's been that way since I was 20
you know rock and roll whatever but it
still comes my way yeah but there's a
lot of reasons to say no to bad
lest you end up the topic of somebody's
blog or yeah that's it's a new world
it's a world and you don't know what's
being recorded you don't know how you're
being set up and this is not conduct I
would be indulging in in 2016 anyway but
in LA all the time I'm eating with my
manager and because we work in the same
office she's been working with me for 20
years and we'll be somewhere eating
lunch and having you know been doing
business stuff and she'll go okay we
can't do any more business I said wash
is it one table behind it's the guys
recording us Wow and you look going this
guy like holding his phone it happens
all the time or someone is listening or
someone is taking photos and that's the
world where you're super celebrity
yeah and with romance there is no way
you're meeting a nice gal in Buffalo and
having a night of fun and frolic there's
no way she's keeping that to herself
because she you know I don't know how
cool she is or not cool but she's gonna
tell a friend and her friends
immediately gonna post it and their
money they're in physics then huh even
in place that Kazakhstan or somewhere
like that where you meet someone who
you're not really a celebrity um who
knows yeah but for me none of that is
worth the risk of myriad potential
downsides
I've been extraordinarily lucky in my
life I've been to the the deli tray many
many times no questions on what can be
done yeah and it's all been really
wonderful but when I'm traveling my
priorities are all about getting
information getting great photos yeah
like in Antarctica you're on a boat full
of scientists or when I was in Ecuador
last year I'm on a boat full of
scientist botanist naturalist learning
about codependent ecosystems
biodiversity I was in rain four cells on
the Napo River I'm taking notes I'm
working I'm at these lectures
like on the boat on the way to the
Antarctic Peninsula learning about sea
ice katabatic winds I'm getting
information I'm working because it's all
gonna turn into articles my next book my
next photo book meeting people is solo
on my world meeting someone to frolic
with is solo on my level of interest you
know do you make on the other hand then
do you make friends while you're gone
where you can like stay in touch though
I'm always polite to everyone I'm sure
it's a rapport environment like a ship
it's like prison or imagine an airplane
flight that lasts eight days you have to
be cool because your first impression
you never if you're if you're as short
with someone like yeah yeah you never
get that you never undo that that's a
Gordian knot of what is perceived as
disrespect you'll never untangle it
right and so on a ship you sit at some
table so Henry what do you do
and so my god you don't know him sons of
anarchy
or they'll say something and you're like
look like oh my god I have seen you and
you go yeah and so now the rest of the
dinner is gonna be about you now and so
what I do is I go yeah yeah you know I
get some interesting jobs and I deflect
and I say well were you two from oh
we're from Nebraska up into Nebraska
it's very nice and you just get it away
from you
otherwise someone walks away going God
all he did was like talk about himself
no all you do is ask me about me and
what it's like to hang out with Will
Smith and bad boys to or whatever and I
get asked all that and so I am very much
bouncing it away from me and not making
the trip about me but I get you know
everyday you'll sit down to some table
in the lunch room and someone will go so
I saw you once in 1985 and like okay and
all of that happens to me and then the
whole staff comes up goes like
we knew you're coming on the boat we're
all fans and you know professionally
we're not allowed to acknowledge that
but like we do photos later I'm like
yeah whatever you guys want man it's
cool no like you know we're not swell I
don't know I get it I get it
it's cool and so eventually another it
just happens and so in those in closed
environments that's almost a guarantee
and those who don't know who you are
by Saturday they do really yeah and
they'd like a soul someone yesterday
told me that you've been in some films
what might I seen you in like okay and
you give them the most agree theatres
before all your credits and although I
guess yes that's it because I'm not
interested in making anything about me
no in those situations you have to see
these people every day so just be as
insanely cool as possible and I've been
on boats for like long pierce the Nile
or whatever and there's a real ethic to
it just be real like you know you never
go into politics and these votes I was
on you know they're talking about the
election the Americans were and the
Brits always like to chime in of course
everyone has an opinion about American
politics cuz it's duck dynasty it's very
bad reality TV right and they go so
Henry I'm like you know I just want
everyone who can vote to vote not my
business smart because I just it's just
not it's that submarine thing one of the
things never talks with anybody yes
please in these quarantined and enclosed
you're in a capsule for a week in a
hospital hit you just be neutral you
know be Switzerland is Bill Maher once
said I used to I said last night I did I
used to tell them as an independent
contractor so wasn't yeah I'm not lying
in that way I you know I get into it
when we get into these countries that
you know you and I go to any tourist any
traveler you have to put down occupation
and years ago when I was doing music all
the time I'll just write down music not
even musician I start music now I no
longer do music and so
I always hesitate I go what what should
I put down writer well I do write but I
wouldn't call myself a writer and that
sometimes I'll just write down radio cuz
I do have a radio show for all just put
down actor but that as at the custom L
you're an actor what have I seen you in
yoake never again so let's write down
radio so I can say KCRW National Public
Radio they already there they go to
sleep I can't even stamp your passport
is so busy falling asleep in front of
you you see National Public like alright
enough let you in because but it's true
I have shown in PR I love AFP art it's
just like that local whatever they're
called where they talk about like paving
a street like the City Council meetings
I find it today for seven hours we're
gonna teach them how to bind a book must
be NPR yeah and and so try I'm 55 and a
half as the years go on and my body
hurts more and more travel becomes more
and more important to me because I have
more years behind me than ahead of me
and I seek to live in a more legendary
fashion I'm I live I try work at it and
this sounds like you know hoods but but
it's true I make a very conscious effort
to live a fascinating life I work at it
like okay six weeks off I don't want to
sit at home can the only thing I miss
about Los Angeles is my records where I
can put on a record and listen to it I
miss that and I'll be back for 48 hours
soon and I know the exact records all
these new records that have just come
out since I've been gone I know exactly
what I'm gonna listen to I could I have
that I got like at least five hours on
Monday to do some good listening and I
got already got it lined up I was I'm
gonna be gone from my turntable till
December when I start a long run at
Largo and so what he wasn't too I mean
what am I gonna listen to the new
dinosaur jr. the new Oasys records don't
make a music dinosaur much better
really on this called give a glimpse of
what you're not and it is so good I've
had an advance copy for a while but not
the vinyl and it is so good love those
guys some seven times last year anyway
really I say I have like six weeks off
next year
like whatever pick a month with any
month yeah I will take that six weeks
and go what is the most interesting
mind-blowing thing I can put myself
through in that time oh look there's
scuba diving off this south coast of
China book it cuz I'm certified for 180
feet and nitrous in my cylinder so I
said you know that would be a potential
trip I'd make next year or a buddy of
mine he's a dive instructor he takes
groups all over the world I'd call Ron
and go Ron June 1st through the end of
the month where you guys going anywhere
cool we're going to the Galapagos I'm in
I think he says no nothing then you're
like next next thing off man oh then
when you do have something interesting
well in November we're gonna go to okay
man I'll be back in touch with you and
then I'll call Gina or Rita rather Reena
the travel agent okay June July she is
okay I go New Guinea she's nope rainy
season I go okay I go would he suggest
yes okay well you've been to Kuala
Lumpur I don't know she's alright
this Malaysia if you never been spent
much time in Malaysia
it's a cool part of the year or I let
her make a suggestion but usually I have
my my own I go and like two years ago I
had November and party December off and
I said um Central Asia cuz I've been
promising myself Central Asia for a
while I'm fascinated by that part of the
world and so I did a month in Central
Asia and I'd read a book it she was
alright and here's all your stats get a
good you know have a safe trip to get
tips from people like either on Twitter
or just in life like oh I went to this
oh hell no Tomato Festival this people
on the boat in Antarctica they we one
day we're every day you have lectures
and meetings and they go okay everyone
we made landfall today everyone put
their foot on and did the continent so
hands up for everyone who's been to all
seven continents
it's out of like like what 60 people or
whatever it was maybe two hands didn't
go up and you have dinner with some old
South African guy who now lives in
Brazil and his stories of travel peel
the paint off yours like he took my
travel stories and put into a ball of
paper as big as a gum wrapper and
flicked it about that room I said so uh
you know the Middle East my friend in
1975 I I rented a motorcycle and we went
from you know our way from Kabul to and
you're like you are killing these guys
have travel stories like we were in
Mongolia for two months and we were
living we were choppered into this were
the sheep herders we we hiked the steps
for six weeks followed the Sheep and we
lived in these yurts and like I want to
do that and you'll just find you get
great ideas because you're on you're
traveling with master travelers like
husbands and wives they save their money
and every other year and they've been
married for 40 years like some nice
couple from New Hampshire and you meet
them and they go well we could go out
every year and it'll we're going back
for our sixth trip to China and we go
into the into the lands like you know
five hundred miles out of Beijing and we
know this guy and we'll send you his
address you'll he'll hook you up and
he'll show you things you'll never see
and you're like and I do write these
people and I do keep in touch with him
I'm like I want that guy's I want that
hookups they can give you life oh yeah
and like look we went to five trips we
finally found the right guy he's amazing
and he'll take you he'll set you up with
an airplane and you're gonna fly like
four hours this way and there's a runway
and you're gonna live with these you
know miners for a week and and here's
his number and I follow up because
they've gone four times they finally
found the right guy and I want to take
that trip and then you know you're I
have this amazing travel agent she got
me to North Korea she gets people into
crazy
places where they fly you in and leave
you for two weeks and pick you up and
you spend your time with like sheep
herders or a bunch of monks at the top
of a mountain in you know wherever and
these are trips that I want to do all of
it there's not one of those trips I
don't want to take live with sheep
herders yeah man
or there's one trip you can take
apparently where you can take the salt
trail in is it like Mali or Egypt
where's like a twenty day Trek and these
guys move salt they move a ton of salt
on camel and you can either go on the
back of a camel which will break you in
half or you can walk next to the camel
but you can pay money and you can go and
they kind of act as Sherpas cuz you're
gonna go through a lot of water you're
gonna be puking and apparently it's
really gnarly I just don't know if I
have the physical shape to do it at 55
and a half but there's trips like that
we're yeah we're gonna leave you in a
place for three weeks and you're gonna
get to point B and there'll be another
plane to pick you up
and there's trips you can take like that
there's a woman I know a friend of my
manager she does like three of those a
year because she's got unending amounts
of money literally good Jillian's of
dollars and she has done pretty much the
entire book of those trips Wow whoo
she's like you know hung out with like
the yak herders and all of that in
Mongolia for a month and done all that
crazy stuff I want to do all of it
there's not one of those trips that
doesn't interest me there's not one
river that I haven't been on that I
don't want to go on do you see yourself
from the outside looking in and we like
that guy's cool no you know I just
acknowledge myself as a total maniac
yeah who doesn't I don't care when I die
and I'm just looking to do really
amazing things until it's over what else
is there to live for out how many kids I
don't have a wire I'm not interested in
any of that I'm not putting it down it's
just never been I never had the chip for
that and so uh I have the means I can do
it why not why wouldn't you exactly huh
like if you had dough like you see these
guys he's like Wall Street day traders
with like you know
twenty-five million bucks a year and
they never leave Manhattan I go really
man I'd have a house on every continent
except for maybe Antarctica but like in
Antarctica I was rolling with Jim real
estate there huh probably cheap real
estate there if you want damaging a
beautiful part of the wire but there's
some bases there where they do weather
research and stuff and I there's a an
alliance I made with a staffer on the
ship to geologists and he's been this is
what he does for 14 years he lives down
there part of the year and you know
takes people on tours but he researches
that he's a brilliant geologist and I
was I hung out with him every day
because I you know after the lectures
over on the one with 80 questions in my
steno pad I wore him out but he loved it
and we still email each other and he
sends me all kinds of interesting
articles because I'm genuinely
interested I want to talk to him at some
point go look can you hook me up
so I can spend six weeks at the like
McMurdo base you know in Antarctica I'll
pay like I'm not looking for it I want
to bunk and I want to pay for my chow I
want to pay for my showers and I want to
stay that out of the way I know I'll be
sitting you know Quonset hut 23 hours a
day I get it
but I want to do it or there's that
documenting on the people who live I
think of the Arctic for the dark part of
the year and they just do it they stay
it's like six months of darkness figure
those glasses that well you know yeah
it's the Northern Lights it's you know
the aurora borealis and some insanely -
and they they do the entire cold part of
the year and there's a documentary on
Netflix
I think it's called Arctic something and
I saw that no one I asked my travel
agent I said is there any way I can just
pay because there's people have they run
convenience stores they you know they
run the bowling alley or whatever and I
said can I just pay money and live in
the people who live there all in the
warm part of the year like rent a bunk
or rent someone's apartment or their the
room
the people who leave and and rent it
from them
timeshare basically fly there via
whatever and just pay for my meals pay
for me you know whatever it costs
showers and do six months in this part
of the world where you walk outside for
three minutes and you're dead um I want
to do it just to see what would happen
what the writing would be like and what
the experience would be like and she
said you would do all those months just
for that I'm like oh yeah oh hell yeah
and so um there's lots of things like
that I would like to do some very
extreme travel like you will live alone
for six months in this cabin you know
and it would do something to you I think
cuz I feel like a few days if I can't
handle this and after like two weeks you
like now it's a new moments right now
after three months you be okay I've lost
my mind and recovered it three times and
I'm really tempted to pick up that Sat
phone and pay for a helicopter to get me
out though I'm not going to do it I'm
gonna see him in the spring if there's
things like that available to a citizen
like me I am willing to take it I just
thought I recognized that guy walking by
looked like Thurston Moore Sonic Youth
but it's not oh what am i cool yeah I
wouldn't be surprising to see him here
but that's the kind of travel I'm up for
now
weird isolation and extreme conditions
fascinate me
and there's another trip in an article
one can take I'm looking to take it a
year from this November it's what the
trip I just took with an extra few weeks
tacked on to the beginning where you go
through the South Georgian islands and
you see the emperor penguins the big
ones because I was talking to the crew
of the ship and I said I got to do this
again they said Henry you're so curious
you really need to come back on this
ship we're not looking for your money
we're just saying come at a different
time of year like if you come in
December like all the the breeding
penguins you saw you'll see the chicks
hatching out
like all the snow you saw Italy mud all
the water you saw will be full of whales
like you come back here in a month and
all this changes like come back in a
year but come in December and you'll see
the same places but everything will be
different and they said and if you want
there's a longer trip we do like every
other time or whatever we do the South
Georgian Islands and the trip where you
got on the boat that's just a stopover
and it's like three or four weeks on
this boat and you'll get your mind blown
with everything you'll see but it's a
big commitment and it's not cheap must
be respected
and I said I'll see you on that there's
no way I'm not doing it and I'm looking
for that in 2017 this must give you
respect for nature saying stuff like
this I started I've never done eco
travel before until last year where I
wanted to learn more about where my food
comes from and it was a combination of
things and one of the things that led me
to going on the Napo River a tributary
of the Amazon to learn about
biodiversity and see all that this
freshwater dolphin and really try and
get it my head around some basic
concepts of biodiversity and codependent
ecosystems was learning to scuba dive
and going face up with sea lions and
fish because you look at them and they
look at you - they totally check you out
you they come right up to your mask and
or arias and the sea lions are very
curious for a min and then they get
bored of you and they swim off and I
said okay this is blowing my mind I want
to know more and I usually don't go for
flora and fauna trips because you know a
tree yeah you know yeah
dissing it but I want cities I want
bullet casings I want to see where
turmoil was I want to go to a country
where there's an election I want to see
urban stuff that's my interest but last
year I said I want to do travel I've
never done and Heidi said to me she said
you know you never go to South America
you go everywhere else you got to start
going to South America I said you know
what you're right and so I started going
to South last year I was in South
America
Bunch in Chile and Argentina Ecuador
which is so beautiful Quito up in the
mountains forget it's incredible
you're jammed up in the Andes I'd go
back in a heartbeat
really South America is a place I wanted
to the people are so friendly it almost
spoils you you come back to America or
wherever it's like you know you know
what's up [ __ ] here here's your food
where you know you do a month of hola
you're like why leave yeah there's this
a neon sign on the cow gate at some bar
it's a quote I don't know who said it
but it's not all who wander are lost and
uh yeah what is David Lee Roth once said
to me yeah and I don't know where he got
it from he said let me know let me see
if I can get this right in one take
tourists a traveler doesn't know where
he's going
a tourist doesn't know where he is where
you know I go to these countries and I'm
like so what are you to do today that
way yeah what's there I don't know man I
got to go I got to travel to find out
like you know what's this city like I'll
tell ya after I get out of there
hopefully with all my fingers and toes
my friends and I went Chiang Mai and
we're stand on this alley we couldn't
decide what was down there it fed out or
something was a falafel stand at the
beginning of it and went further we kept
looking at it like should we go down
there so we continue on this road it's
some other random guy comes by and he
goes you're just gonna regret not going
in and he may as well see it like you're
right bird you're right let's just go
there's only been a few streets in my
life I've not gone usually I'm walking
alone yeah we have you know some pro
camera gear in my hand and I get to the
edge of us Street and I'm like and I gut
check it I'm like okay the guts saying
like mmm south of good so of course I go
and so my strategy is if you're going
into a slum you don't know what's around
the corner so I go without my camera
away
so if anyone's lining me up to take that
camera and they're waiting for me to
come out because
there's one Road in and out so they know
they're gonna see me in half an hour
yeah and they're gonna be ready I take
my photos on the way out
like a guy backing out of a bank stick
them up so they don't get a bead on you
and what you got yep yep you play poker
and I'm not trying to say all they all
want your money but it's on a one on one
skinny guy and I'm not looking to defend
myself with a guy with a knife I'm not I
don't have some karate move and so but
most the time people are like super
friendly I come in come in meet my
family I'm like all right and so I go in
and on my way out
I've already like seen the lay of the
land you know I'm looking at photo ops
I'm dialing in f-stop settings in my
head like okay so I'll be down I'm gonna
bump up the ISO I'm already getting my
manual dialing ins for this shot on my
way back and I make my move on the way
out Wow yeah
what is it about what is it about that
type of person that type of traveler
who's like what makes them that the one
who's like I got a C [ __ ] I don't know
but I've always had it and I always
loved the idea cuz I'm on stage like
this this year 150 shows in 19 countries
I don't do comedy sometimes what I say
is funny you're not writing stuff to be
funny I'm telling you something that
happened in Iran and a lot of it was
funny and some of it was really sad or
poignant or relevant or interesting and
and so I need to be able to go onstage
and blow minds
a draw I mean some people to say because
I don't have hey you know my dog said I
don't have any of that
I'm not putting comedians down I wish I
had that talent what I have is it is
insane world travel stories and so this
year's at or year 150 some shows I've
been out since December of last year 150
something shows 100 and I'm about 50 in
I have another hundred to go yeah and in
19 countries and I get back on Sunday
from here I'm already 15 in and so I'm
gonna go in
two days I get home I gonna go right to
New Zealand four shows a month in
Australia then to South Africa and then
America till the end of the year and
then up into Canada till like Jan 10 and
then I'm out the tour's over and then
I'll be back in Hollywood begging for
work during pilot season and you know
weekend dates you know as we do fly out
fly back but this is the big year for
touring and I do one of these big world
tours like every few years and it's the
last time was a hundred and ninety shows
which is what I prefer so I only got a
hundred and fifty this time around but
getting everything in at once and then
and then build up a new material in the
next year exactly and so in the off
years I'm traveling gathering new stuff
to trot out on stage I'm getting
information I'm letting the information
steep getting the the wisdom from the
story so it's not just sheer reportage
like you go to Central Asia you see a
bunch of mosques and madrasahs but two
weeks after you come back you start
thinking like well what's the lyric in
the story where's the poetry what's the
the thing of it he was trauma human
trauma and cultural crisis because what
Genghis Khan's Mongols didn't level in
the beginning of the 13th century like
12 twenty-something the Mongols came in
like level Central Asia just crushed it
uh-huh and the Chinese came in the Arabs
get all these people came in and gave
the Arabs came and gave him Islam and
then the Soviets came in and shut down
the madrasahs and the mosques and screw
those people up and then in 1991 all
those countries got their independence
you go through all these cities there's
Islamic writing Arabic there's Latin you
know English or European French and then
there's Cyrillic Russian and I asked
these guys you can't get through Central
Asia without a guide you just can't get
the border crossing so really you'd have
to pay a lot of money hey I really need
to go there here and so you need someone
to finesse the crossings otherwise it's
just too spread out you need a
rent-a-car is that everything is a
hundred
miles distance so you need a guide also
you can tell you who to bribe to huh
let's tell you who to bribe to the
camera but let's say you trying to get
to America it's tough to bribe an
official there right have to know who
and where
but um yeah Central Asia without a guide
there's no way I would have seen all the
things I saw but after two weeks of
reflection after seeing those cities I
asked the guy like well wait a minute
what are you guys are you products of
Soviet overreach are you is this an
Islamic country what are you guys and he
and one sharp guide said we're figuring
that out and so when I talk about that
trip on stage I talked about the
fragility of our species and how easy it
is to traumatize a person like if you
and I were six years old now's the bully
and I called you whatever you'd remember
me
you remember that beating you remember
that humiliation until you're 50
it might even inform why you do stuff
I'm thoroughly energized by the
humiliations of my third grade that
totally charges me and so we humans you
know we remember stuff you you molest us
we stay molested you beat us up we stay
beat up
that's therapy and PTSD for the rest of
your life you traumatize a culture it
goes into the DNA and their kids are
traumatized and two generations later
they don't even know why they're screwed
up because there's no context there's
just in this weird atmosphere and that's
what the takeaway of Central Asia was
and that's what I'm taking to the stage
not this mosque cause they're all
beautiful right it's the fragility of
Homo sapiens and when I learn about
Central Asia from Central Asia I need to
be nicer to you I need to be better to
every stranger I meet because we're
really fragile creatures I'm fragile
you're fragile
we're neurotic too there were just too
many good too many thoughts were too
smart or too fast to uptake in process
to not be nuts and there's no person in
the world who's too so tough that they
can't be broken to tears by an
interrogator by their mom and so like
you
SURS on the first 48 some hard guy and I
didn't kill anybody the mom goes in
maybe you need to tell the truth the guy
breaks down the whole thing because his
mama came in and said you know I'm sorry
mama said to him and mama said tell the
truth and the kick that comes in
something you want to tell me is yeah
man I did it because mama went in there
for a minute and said damn hell and so
anyone can be broken and from Central
Asia I learned no matter how decent I am
I've got work to do I need to upgrade I
need to be even better and that's what I
tell people at the shows this year I
said in my country if Trump wins there's
gonna be lines coming out of out of
Starbucks cuz all the Liberals and the
triple lattes and more wine and more sex
and they're just gonna have existential
crises because an idiot now runs America
if Clinton wins will be lines coming out
of Walmart cuz everyone's buying more
ammo and more booze and more bad food I
said it doesn't matter who wins it's
gonna be a really rough country to live
in because one half is going to be
pissed and I'd rather the left side get
pissed because they drown it out with
wine drugs and coffee where the other
side drowns it out with bullets and
violence and fighting and beating up
people like me and so but it doesn't
matter half the country is gonna be
pissed as a [ __ ] lump it's a bad one
yeah and as I've been saying to my
American audiences this year and
February I did some American shows
around my birthday but the big all the
big American tours I saw them but I did
a handful in the Midwest and I said
whatever happens in November you're just
gonna have to be an amazing person
because we shall not overcome this
country will not overcome what we've
proven it we don't want to we're not we
are not interested you are I am but
we're not because we've had so many
chances from 1865 the end of the Civil
War to make it better and we've dodged
every cow fare already we don't want it
big business doesn't want it the
corporatized democracy doesn't want it
our money comes from weapons weapons
delivery systems and incarceration and
so what gets in the way of all that is
quality education peace and prosperity
and so we don't want that and that's why
what goes on in backrooms is now
happening in the streets where this kids
get shot by cops you never because that
sucks and it just keeps happening and
it's Jim Crow it's in its
institutionalized racism and that's what
happened when you got the 13th amendment
abolished slavery in 1865 in 1868 you
got the 14th amendment making equal
protection the law of the land where the
rich guy as the same rights as the guy
the barista at the coffee place uh-huh
all equal protection would you get out
of that Jim Crow laws the Klan exploding
in numbers and so our country is not
interested in progress you had an
amazing president for eight years he got
hardly anything done but he did get done
because he's a triple level chess player
who managed to nuance this stuff through
Congress and they howled and moaned
that's why he got fractured health care
they got the worst possible version of
that thing it's like pulling an elephant
through a keyhole
they got it through but look at the
elephant that they're all scarred up it
sucks because they these people operate
on inequality that's where the butters
their bread is buttered so if they make
stuff it into the in in it in equal
unequal like that's what the money is
because if you let everyone who's smart
in on the stock market thing that guy's
not making 20 million a month anymore
he's only making 18 he can't live
without the other two because he has to
have it because you know freedom and so
what I've learned about Central Asia is
it's hardly even about Central Asia it's
about the human race and so that's why I
travel to these places I can come back
with a story that sounds like some
prismatic weird non sequitur some
ricochet off where I've been like what
did India teach me the times I've been
there the humanity is beautiful even
when it's dipped in its own fecal matter
when you see a body on a funeral pyre on
fire you watch it fracking hours to
watch some old dude burn which I've done
a few times you just go we'll sis life
is just death nothing to trip on because
the family is watching grandpa burn
they're not crying they're not tripping
we'll see him later he
you know the they'll see him in another
life they're not even sweating it as a
Western you're like guys are fired damn
they're looking at you like a tourist
yeah they don't care it's just life and
this is the wisdom of travel because you
can't get this from a documentary
because you can't smell it you can't get
it from a book you're not walking over
it my first day in India I saw nine dead
people ohyes of a funeral home well I
saw a dead person getting walked down
the street and I smelled smoke and I see
a dead guy in a pile of whistle I'm
going in here and there's a line of
little grandmas and grandpas shriveled
old people on the floor covered in
flowers not just a body just you all
wrapped up ready for the cremation
and this the family is gently moving
Grandma and Grandpa up the line to the
oven because they can't afford the
outdoor and then I hear arguing two men
haggling at the front of the line so I
go to the front of the line I'm just
some Western them sneaking around and
there's the owner of the funeral home
and the relative of the deceased and
they are standing on either side of a
dead woman little old lady on the ground
arguing about the price haggling over
the price of the incineration why they
come to an agreement ah the oven door
opens yeah without any ceremony grandma
goes in close the door and the guys at
ah visiting I said yeah he said come my
friend I want to show you something he
took me behind the oven because it's his
brand-new oven with the digital readout
and he was so proud of the digital
readout like you know six hundred and
forty degrees or whatever I'm like ok
duly noted that's intense and I see I've
seen burnings in India in uh in Bhutan
in Thimphu Bhutan and it's it's edifying
to spend all afternoon watching the
monks do their two hour of prayer where
they're blowing through horns made a few
man thighbone and then they light the
wood on fire and in the cloth
surrounding the body so the first few
minutes it's fluffy white smoke
then it gets too thin oily smoke and you
hear crackling and popping and it's
that's the body that's the lean tissue
burning that's the fat it's just meat
what else is a human smells like a
barbecue
it smells like flesh because the wind
comes your way that's for people it is
what it is all the dogs show up it's not
cruel and unusual
it's how they groove in Bhutan and I was
with a guy named Yellen 10 he was my
guide so I said thank you for letting me
see this it's a pretty heavy event and
without any emotion whatsoever he goes
yeah we cremated my father in that one
on the left and I said all day man I'm
so sorry to have brought you back here
he said why would you be it's cool it's
we don't sweat death I'm happy that you
got to see this
would you it's such a non Western idea I
was so so I thought I didn't rude to
drag him back to this place where they
almost unlevel like my dad went to high
school there right just like exactly
thank you he toss it off that casually
yeah well my we cremated my father and
the one on the on the left I want okay
he says getting dark we need to hike
through the mud to get back to the
parking lot we should go okay I took
photos all day the photos are amazing of
fires and smoke and dogs and people and
how many these books we put out I've
written and published over 25 books I've
been robbed us no one photo book the
next one's done but I've been publishing
books of mine since the 80s I'm in
translation all over the world I've sold
hundreds of thousands of books one of my
books the audio version got a Grammy Wow
really no I'm not so cool believe it or
not some people can sit actually
consider me a writer it started by just
living on the road I was in a band
called Black Flag and I live down the
road and I would see stabbings and
undercover cops at our shows crazy stuff
and I was like 21 going wow I started
buying those tablet notebooks at the
drugstore for two bucks started writing
it all down and then I read Henry Miller
who made me think that I could write too
because I am living in France I was with
this [ __ ] last night and I'm draw
can you read Bukowski ozk another
amazing writer and they both make you
think it's a sucker punch they make it
look so easy
well he's just writing about his life
and then you try and do it you see how
damn hard writing is like you see how
wickedly talented Bukowski and Miller
were when you try and I'm just gonna
write real stuff it's like acting I'm
just gonna say the words on the script
uh-huh
that's way more than that and writing is
way more than just writing down what you
see and feel you need to you need I'm
writing it so you're gonna read it and
get the same wallop that I got that's
the magic
that's what makes gives you your f scott
fitzgerald's and everyone else I delete
someone up to something on a feel your
motion are you yeah and that's why those
writers are so famous and that's why
there's 80 million books that are just
dire crap because a lot of men think
they can write you know you know if you
sit at it long enough you will make a
manuscript four inches thick
you will [ __ ] dammit look it it's a lot
of words I must be a writer I used to
think like that until I met Hubert Selby
the great writer of author of last six
mr. Brooklyn and he used to read my
books and and when I he liked it he
liked it when he didn't like it he you
would too oh yeah oh yeah so I think he
saw something in me but he cuz you got
to get your balls out of the way all you
young guys you put your balls in front
of the right and get your ego out of the
way of the story stop trying to look
good like damn thank you and never
forgot that you guys tell the story
don't talk about you let the story come
through you and like all right you're
coddling is the worst thing you're gonna
do for someone for anybody it's how you
lose a race it's how you lose the
Olympics it's how you get killed it's
how you don't bring all your soldiers
back from a mission it's just doesn't
help anyone so you guys are trained
enough I'm sure you're fine yeah no
it'll be cool no the valleys gentlemen
it's peaceful uh-huh know your writings
great owner your new Bahamas fantastic
you know your A&R guy should tell you
your new songs suck you guys really need
to stop arguing and get to work I sit up
in the comedians all the time [ __ ]
people bug no no this goes bad crowd is
a bad crowd and I'm like don't tell them
that yeah just chillin oh here you kill
him and if that guy had a shred of hope
you're gonna help him self-immolate cuz
he won't understand he won't see it when
it hits him because you didn't help him
he won't look no to look right and he's
gonna get run over
yeah because you should have told them
your materials average but you're better
than your materials so so get to work
that's why a lot of musicians fail they
get that group around them they just
immense so ya know those people tell
them I'll be there eight to go man that
was a great show tonight was so bad hey
man they don't understand you man
they don't understand you well yeah with
those than you can never look inwards
you got to be like they're all idiots
yeah no matter what the critics say DOS
I was lame like when I face-planted and
passed out on stage hey they don't
understand you're under a lot of stress
I was punk rock yeah it wasn't the
heroin it's the stress yeah no no
biessing anyone the only reason you do
it is to like it would be a sunsoo
strategic move you weaken your enemy so
you can music is great so you can like
you know take his management and you
know take his woman next year it's how
you win the fight you know oh my arm
hurts with my am and you just hit the
guy yeah
yes Sun Tzu wrote the book the ER the
art of the war you know feign weakness
and when your opponent lows or lowers
his guard you kill him that's the mother
level is yeah but it's one of the many
things he teaches you in his book it's
called the Japanese Wall Street trader
book it's how the the Japanese trade
that that's that's their Bible for
trading really as this is the other word
of war yeah yeah it's a fun book it's
skinny he can fit it in your breast
pockets a tiny little read it's like
Machiavelli it's it's dense but it packs
a punch they forget that Redbook in
China the quotes of mal no oh I got what
small honor you leave through it and
there's some good ideas in there man
Mao is intense I'm no expert but he was
a radical dude he put his followers
through a whole lot China's worth going
to have been there a bunch of times it's
trippy I don't I'm no expert on I've not
traveled it much I've just been to
Beijing and Shanghai a bunch yeah and I
really want to get out into it someday
but Beijing is an amazing city is
fascinating and psychedelic and its
strangeness it's just so weird it's just
so without these 16 Lane wide streets
just
- and then - two blocks over there's the
hutongs that are like what is this he's
don't even
there's not even parallel streets like
yeah how do they go yeah there you can
get lost easily I always stay in a hotel
about four blocks from Tiananmen Square
it's a raffles it's a good Asian chain
and I know the the the manager when I
use Beijing as a hub like when I went to
North Korea I didn't go with my laptop
and he puts it all in his office so I've
John his his name John's hooked me up
more than once and I've kind of used his
hotel is kind of a launch pad listen
come back in this Beijing is the place
the hub to go up to Mongolia and back
North Korea and back right pass through
Beijing and go to the raffles and use
that Haute you know give him business
and he looks out for me I gave him a
backpack of stuff I go look I here's
like a bunch of clothes and food I just
can't take it to North Korea don't know
if I'm gonna get out of these I'll put
it my office next to my door it'll be
safe that's great thank you
and he looked after like my other camera
body and other lenses like tons of stuff
to try to stay offline when you go to
these places or do you like detective I
can't I I'm responsible for to hand in
things it's tricky like google.ca CH is
a tricky browser to maneuver being in
any Central Asian country with a they do
censor the internet like in a
Turkmenistan I stupidly tried to look up
the human rights records of Turk Mills
and was kicked off the internet for 15
minutes they put you in the penalty box
really mm-hmm yep anytime you look for
anything dumbass not here yeah and they
will literally go block site blocked
site block site and I tricked him I was
able to find information on Turkmenistan
by going to a Southeast Asian newspaper
that had a report so I went through
their net their newspaper and got to the
article and somehow is able to you know
wear the glasses with the fake nose and
mustache the Ebers another and I had to
say I did a feature for time out UK and
they wanted to do is a photo of things
they wanted my photos and me writing
about it when I was in Beijing and I had
to get out of the hotel there's a frozen
yogurt place they left they free
internet
they left their internet thing on so I'm
sitting hiding in a parking lot so the
cops don't roll by because they're gonna
come right up to me because I'm lit with
a lot laptops like 4:00 in the morning
and I'm sneaking out of google.ca CH to
America forgot how I did it
through AOL like using aol.com as a
laundromat and laundered my images like
out of China through America to the UK
I'm just totally radio shacking this
because I'm a Luddite and it worked and
it took like 10 minutes per photo but I
was on deadline my handi had not counted
on China not allowing me to send these
images and I was like okay and I did the
Sun started coming up I'm like okay my
bones were aching my god too old for
this but um these are these this life I
have out in the world and I have an
identity out here you know I'm not this
traveller guy I understand myself out
here I've earned my familiarity with
cities like I'm in Melbourne I know
exactly the the restaurants I like when
I'm in Tokyo I know where I want to go I
know all my favorite neighborhoods in in
Dubai because I earned it I've been
there enough times I went out on the
streets I like having that Mark Twain II
and worldly global perspective I live
for that it's cool yeah all right thanks
man you got it in touch beautified with
Henry Rollins calm Henry Rollins calm
always finds me you can all your writing
and stuff to that I'm sorry you can find
all your writings and stuff there that
they can find yeah all my books are on
our website for sale and I always have
new books you know there's like four I'm
working on as simultaneously and next
year there'll be minimum one but
probably two books out in 2017 it's a
lot of the time to edit the books are
done I've got to edit you know I only
edit with a Heidi who manages me we edit
together we've been doing it for years
I don't edit without her so I trust her
you're like no well she knows my brain
very well so I do the first edit typos
and you know big awful sentences I get
that out of the way and she and I do the
second draft and then a woman and
a woman named Carol does the third draft
looking for you know typographical
errors like commas and periods on the
wrong size of quotation marks or
whatever yeah yeah and their tour
schedules up there to the tour all the
tour dates are up and I'm open for
business to come to the show oh yeah I
wanted to see it we're overlapping my
early shows the same time as yours
everyone to see for a while could play
cause like I get your tickets let me
know when yeah I guess let's seed you
for any of that no but um if I've been
doing a bunch of shows up Largo in
December to just talk to Matt or go to
my site you'll see all of them and like
six remember how I'm gonna go through
the world huh I think the samurai gonna
be okay they're gonna see the world if
something blows out you want to go I'll
be there like starting December 7 for
like a week okay so and and just ask
Matt he'll guess listen for any of those
shows even that's all though did you
killed on my show well most fun
yeah it's functional good great I know
you don't want to be in that place but
once I'm on stage I don't care where I
am you know you're just doing it but
everyone was nice to me rotten white
that's the guy's name he was very nice
to me he watched me and he came up
afterwards said man that was great
I'll take it yeah I was like that guy's
a player but yeah that was a fun show
thanks for letting me be part of the
game for a night yeah you're welcome
yes cool it's awesome well thanks thanks
all right
oh oh oh that's it you guys that's the
episode that's the episode good episode
I know
it was a long intro
yeah good episode man I'm glad I did
that
glad I did that with them so cool that I
was able to [ __ ] come and sit with me
and tell me all that stuff Henry Rollins
everybody I gotta see that show I got it
see what that show is like it seems so
interesting she was a really good
storyteller on my show you guys got to
look it up I'll put it on the website
you guys gotta look up this is not
happening playlists and again new ones
are coming soon Tampa Bay this Thursday
Friday Saturday Chicago Thursday that
after that what is that one the come on
get there 22nd and then Rosemont at 23rd
and 24th then Denver the 25th and then
Austin Texas 2nd 3rd 4th and 5th of
November other than that I'll be in New
York working out getting ready um I was
like just gonna say anyway he is very
cool
what was he gonna say oh I don't know
but it was cool getting to do this with
him in Annenberg all I want to see a
shot want to see a show that's what I
want to say yeah I get it
new episodes of my show and then I did
my dates there boom now I got there I
got there guys smoking less pot my
memory is coming back I feel it I feel
like I've gotten better memory I mean I
remember all four years of my life right
now all that his goal does not glitter
by JRR tolkien first fantasy novel the
Lord of the Rings it alludes to an
integral part of the plot and describes
Aragorn son of Arathorn
this poem appears twice in the Lord of
the Rings first of all you Fellowship of
the Ring it first appears all right
whatever
is repeated by Bilbo Jackson or whatever
all that his goal does not glitter not
all those who wander are lost the old
that is strong does not wither deep
roots are not reached by the frost from
the ashes of fire shall be woken a light
from the shadow shall spring renewed
shall be blade that was broken the
crownless again shall be king Oh his
name is Strider that's who did it
Aragorn
he was Strider he was the guy who'd
[ __ ] wandered around that's [ __ ]
scout you know doesn't even need a
little arm clock dude my memory that is
from the book that is not from the movie
that is from the book even the movie was
a long time ago
he doesn't need alarm clock he just
wakes up he just knows how to wake up at
the right time that is from the book
that is a [ __ ] Hebrew Academy memory
I was gone there and let the tenth
graders in my last year and that was
over there once I was at the high school
side I remember where I was read dead he
still hold my dumps in because I afraid
to let him go out stay in turtle my
underwear every time Yeah right
guys don't forget use my Amazon link do
her shopping through that through the
Amazon Lincoln already the great calm
and that's where you can see all my
dates to get tickets for all my shows
anyway yeah that was that was at weight
worth I think okay let's I think that
was 7th 8th grade who wears 9th 10th
11th 12th that was 4 5 6
no that was senior okay so that was 9th
or 10th grade that I read that so that's
a memory from ninth or 10th grade dude
yeah yeah
older version earlier version of the
poem recorded the treason of Isengard
part of the history of middle-earth book
series by Christopher Tolkien all that
his gold is not glitter all that is long
does not look just excuse me all that
his gold does not glitter all that is
long does not last all that is old does
not wither not all that is over is past
second quatrain was added during the
following revision not all that had
follow excuse me not all that have
fallen are vanquished a king may yet be
without crown a blade that was broken be
brandished and towers that were strong
may fall down that's it I'm done reading
this book this chapter this [ __ ] poem
thank you very much to Henry Rollins for
doing that
yeah I want to go to some other places I
want to see some [ __ ] all right you guys
let's call it I think I don't think I
have anything to discuss other than a
Fuzzle muzzle oh yeah you guys do you
have a dog that's an [ __ ] do you have
a dog that's an [ __ ] you know I mean
where it's like oh you use your precious
baby but then when he gets around anyone
he's yours barking and trying to nip and
bite at them
[ __ ] dogs you know what I'm talking
about kid you be normal dog dog dog get
you be normal you ruin everything Doug
well what are your options don't take it
out ever kill it obviously but you know
putting up [ __ ] right I got like a
rope or belt around his neck and then
tying the one hand over around a pipe in
the pulling are you a monster or muzzle
should always do muzzle but those
muscles look gross they look terrible
they're all like they look like S&M
bondage [ __ ] they're scary it can look
like Franken dog why not get something
better looking oh I know
the Fuzzle muzzle it's out now you guys
this is not an advertisement I just like
the product get the Fuzzle muzzle I
don't even have a dog the Fuzzle muzzle
it's like it's a cool way pretty colors
you're not to be embarrassed anymore Oh
your dog he looks pitiable it looks
totally portable instead of [ __ ]
lightning bolts going off behind them
it's clouds coming in with the [ __ ]
regular muzzle the Fuzzle muzzle puzzle
muzzle calm order yours today and by the
way that app I was talking about last
week was called laughable la ugh a ble
it's pretty cool what happens is you end
up getting someone's podcast and you
find out who the guests are from their
find their podcast it's great way to
find new podcast and it's super easy to
go forward and backwards while you're
listening it's a [ __ ] great app [ __ ]
Steve Jobs death who ever Tim at Cook is
now he doesn't do [ __ ] they don't do a
good their podcast app sucks that
laughing one's pretty good
maybe I'll try to put links to that one
on my site so we'll just open up there
but it's only for phones it's not for
computers anyway
whatever but I think you could play on
computers - I don't know I gotta look
into it more
that's it you guys back to America back
to America I still have another podcast
or two that from out of the country but
the intros will be in America don't want
to be the interest to be in America two
countries a year I got four this year
Dublin excuse me I'm already sorry
Ireland I'm already sorry Ireland
I'll talk about new countries here
Ireland Norway Sweden Iceland which
one's favorite Iceland stop it Iceland
I like Norway though well I don't know I
liked everything
Denmark - I love Denmark and Stockholm
was pretty fun but I just kind of hung
out here a little bit Yoshi helped take
make me around didn't open mic anyway
all right you guys
go to sleep I'm gonna leave for the
airport in [ __ ] three hours
22600 I'll just I'll just do all this on
the phone up there on that plane
uh rather so dry why would I get peanuts
and these [ __ ] Polly puffs how first
Polly first but no water oh I know why
because I said the water was good enough
to drink in Stockholm
I'll Brian flip the town you guys thank
you for turning up I think that's it
right all right for Henry Rollins I'm
Ari Shaffir saying so long for skeptic
tank episode 277 not all those who
wander are lost and by the way thank you
for all the people who give photoshop
work so I can put some dumb photoshop on
the website and on some phones it goes
as a background to the episode
they're just goofy fun photo shops I put
it out on Twitter
here's on Sunday like hey we're going to
do a Photoshop here's what the episodes
about here's the [ __ ] guests and they
come back and make me laugh but once I
use the ones I tell you some of them are
like ridiculously bad those make me
laugh and if that's the only one I've
used those before that's like the only
one full submit but it's just like I
don't know [ __ ] what comes to mind
people do it the funny I use one of them
I give him credit on Twitter on my
website and so they got to throw those
in thank you cuz uh
there's always make you laugh and they
make the guests laugh no [ __ ]
what's-his-name loved it ty Humphries
love the ones who saw the two he saw he
really loved them all right you guys
thank you very much
over was that guy's name
haha
Oh
then run a line a line if they wanted a
wedding it wasn't it
go ahead and what it was
yeah
what a man what a man what a name what
an employment